1835.
The American Frontier.
A beacon of hope in a world choked with blood
and smog.
Little did the hopeful citizens of a still
newly-independent United States know, the
evils of the old world had followed them here.
Sometimes it took the form of hate, of violence.
Of desperation and starvation.
But sometimes, pure evil wasn’t just some
abstract concept, existing in and around all
of us.
Sometimes, that evil - that pure cruelty,
malice, and greed - walks in the shape of
a man.
One such man was James Anderson, an unremarkable
name for a truly exceptional man.
Exceptional in the sense that if most human
beings aren’t willing to sell out all of
humanity for their own petty gain, James Anderson
is definitely the exception.
After all, it’s by his design that we have
SCP-001, the anomaly that set the SCP Foundation
- and our entire reality - down its current
path.
Of course, you know the deal with SCP-001.
Not one anomaly, but many.
A collective designation for a vast number
of entries, all of which spell beginnings
or ends for the SCP Foundation and sometimes
even our universe.
Scarlet Kings, Howling Black Moons, Ouroboros
Cycles, and Gate Guardians.
You’ve heard them all, and seen the files.
But unlike all the others, there is no file
for The Factory.
That’s because the full story only exists
in the mind of O5-1, one of the most powerful,
and arguably the oldest, member of the SCP
Foundation.
He’ll die before he ever commits the story
to paper.
Some memories are just too awful to record.
Their details and implications are too painful
to ever subject others to.
SCP-001 isn’t just about Anderson and his
atrocities, it’s about all the terrible
nightmares that unfolded afterward - and the
deal with the devil that O5-1 struck to lock
them away.
For now, at least.
But it all begins with James Anderson.
His family had become incredibly wealthy in
the Revolutionary War, and in the decades
since, his fortune had only multiplied, as
fortunes tend to do.
In the early 1800s, he began work on his beautiful
and horrific magnum opus: The Anderson Factory.
It would be the pinnacle of the Industrial
Revolution.
The manufacturing plant to end all manufacturing
plants.
Three stories tall and a mile wide.
Company towns had existed for a long time,
but this time, the factory itself was the
town.
It had everything a worker would ever need:
They would live, sleep, play, and most importantly
of all, work, in the same place.
They would never need to leave.
All their wants and needs, from cradle to
grave, would be met in The Anderson Factory,
and all that Mr. Anderson ever asked in return
was loyalty and service.
Was that really so much to ask from those
whom he gave everything?
It may sound like a horrifying form of indentured
servitude to us, but to the people in the
United States in the early 1830s, this kind
of security and stability was a godsend.
To many itinerant workers and unstable families
across the planes, James Anderson seemed like
a saint.
Little did they know, his plans for the factory,
and them, were anything but saintly.
Nobody knows exactly what type of dark magic
James Anderson devoted himself to.
Many have theorized as to whether it was Satan
he worshipped, ancient pagan deities, or something
older and more powerful than both.
In actuality, the only thing that James Anderson
really worshipped was himself, and the pursuit
of more material wealth and power over his
fellow man.
Any pacts he made with evil timeless gods
were just means to an end.
The Anderson Factory was a citadel to one
man’s cruelty and corruption, and every
element of the building’s design seemed
to reflect that.
Groups of eight were forced into rooms together
like battery-farmed chickens to maximize cost-efficiency.
People worked day and night, in shifts of
three.
Machines always rumbled and roared and chewed.
When workers died in factory accidents and
their blood spilled on the ground, it seemed
to reveal arcane symbols carved into the stonework.
These symbols were only visible when blood
flowed across them.
While people traveled hundreds of miles to
live and work at the Anderson Factory, they
had no idea that they were working towards
slavery, subjugation, and death under Anderson’s
iron will.
And, in some cases, fates much, much worse.
The factory remained in operation like this
for forty years, while Anderson himself enjoyed
a positive public reputation as a groundbreaking
industrialist.
How Anderson got away with his crimes for
so long is sadly a tale as old as time: The
factory made valuable products and an awful
lot of profit.
So, no matter how many rumors swirled about
inhumane practices or arcane rites going on
in the Anderson Factory, nothing was ever
done.
It was just too inconvenient to ever reckon
with the horrible truth underneath the productive
surface.
And it truly was productive.
The factory was so huge and filled with such
a multitude of enslaved workers, there wasn’t
anything they didn’t produce.
From textiles to technology, to crops and
meat.
The machines were always on.
The furnaces always burned.
Anderson himself seemed obsessed with two
things: Efficiency and misanthropy - the contempt
and hatred for humanity itself.
He believed his workers were lower than him,
they only existed as a means to his nightmarish
ends.
And if ever the workers became too injured
to work, well, that doesn’t mean that Anderson
wouldn’t still find ways to put them to
“good” use...
The lucky ones, starved and neglected, or
broken by the stress of work or the grinding
gears of the machines, were used as material
in the production of products.
Some were drained of blood, so that it could
be used in the forging of metal.
Others were ground up into meat slurry and
used to pad out the beef, making it go further.
People all across the country enjoying fine
Anderson-brand steaks had no idea they were
actually dining on human flesh the whole time.
But as we said, the ones who ended up being
cooked into steaks and hamburgers after death
were the lucky ones - because at least they
got to die.
The truly unlucky injured workers became the
subject of James Anderson’s horrific occult
experiments.
Using a mix of twisted science and black magic,
he turned men into abominations.
Powerful, terrifying monsters, stronger and
more deadly than any mortal man.
Anderson was building himself an anomalous
army.
But it wasn’t just monsters.
There were just as many so-called “normal”
humans helping him rule over the Anderson
Factory with an iron fist.
They were vicious sadists themselves, spurred
on by absolute loyalty to their immoral master.
It was only after the Civil War that someone
finally escaped the Anderson Factory and confirmed
that not only were the most horrific rumors
about the place true, but they didn’t even
come close to covering the totality of what
was going on there.
When President Grant heard the reports, he
was disgusted.
As far as he was concerned, the atrocities
of James Anderson should not be allowed to
go on a minute longer.
The directive was simple: Find the factory,
free its prisoners, and put James Anderson
to death for his crimes.
And thankfully, President Grant had the perfect
group of operatives for the job.
They were an elite unit of around 150 soldiers
who performed a number of dangerous missions
beyond enemy lines down South.
Espionage, assassination, psychological warfare.
But these missions weren’t just against
the Confederates.
Some of the enemies they faced down South
were things that could not be explained: The
strange, the frightening, the anomalous.
And the highest-ranking soldier in this unit
was a man who would one day become the legendary
O5-1.
He and his men made their long and treacherous
journey to the factory, a trip that would
change all of their lives forever.
When they reached their destination, they
first had to deal with Anderson’s security
force.
These were men whose cruelty and loyalty to
Anderson far outweighed their skill in combat.
While they may have felt powerful when tormenting
starving, injured factory workers, they were
quickly routed and slaughtered by O5-1 and
his team.
When they ventured inside the factory, they
were utterly appalled by what they saw.
The inhuman conditions faced by Anderson’s
thousands of victims drove them into a bloodcurdling,
murderous rage.
Almost half of O5-1’s men were lost in the
battle against Anderson’s army of engineered
monsters, but in the end, they prevailed.
Nothing would stop them in their quest for
liberation and vengeance, on behalf of all
that this terrible place had tormented.
They fought their way to Anderson’s office,
where they found him cowering under his desk.
For a man as despicable as Anderson, only
a truly medieval execution would suffice.
O5-1 and his men hanged, drew, and quartered
Anderson over a period of two days.
The sadistic madman died laughing in the end,
saying that while they may kill him, his factory
will never die.
But the factory was no longer his.
In addition to the Factory’s horrors, O5-1
and his men also discovered its wonders - It
wasn’t just normal items and monsters that
The Factory produced.
They were also, thanks to some of Anderson’s
arcane deals, the world’s leading producer
of anomalous items: Skeletal horses that never
tire, shadow cloaks that can transport the
wearer to different dimensions, toy guns that
fire real bullets, even yo-yos that could
flay the skin from anyone they touched.
These were anomalous objects that could shift
the balance of global power.
Items that could give them an advantage against
the things that go bump in the night.
While others among them were greedy or fearful,
the inner circle of O5-1 were united in a
singular purpose: Using the anomalous they
can control to contain the anomalous that
they can’t.
This group took over the Factory, making it
Site Alpha, their first ever containment facility,
and came to be known as the O5 Council.
With funding that came from a mix of blackmail
and friends in high places, this organization
- a burgeoning SCP Foundation - grew more
and more powerful over the ensuing decades.
The tools they gained from the Factory were
pivotal in the continued success of their
mission, and as they discovered more anomalies,
they also put these anomalies to good use.
But in 1911, O5-1 and his new organization
came up against an enemy that even the Factory’s
tools couldn’t help them defeat: A warrior
race known as The Fae, so named because their
only weakness seemed to be a vulnerability
to iron.
But these beings were an order of magnitude
more powerful than humans, or the beasts they’d
once faced in Anderson’s factory.
The Fae handed them defeat after defeat.
But soon, humiliation became decimation, when
an army of the Fae led an assault on the Factory.
It was a day that only O5-1 remembered: The
Fae slaughtered everyone.
Every guard, every researcher, every member
of the O5 Council.
They swept through the factory like a plague
of locusts, leaving only death and destruction
in their wake.
Only O5-1 escaped and survived, and that’s
only because he ran.
As he fled from the Faery forces through the
halls of the Factory, he came upon a door
he’d never seen before.
A huge, golden door, covered in Aramaic script.
He fled inside, entering the very heart of
the factory.
Inside, he saw the floating dead body of James
Anderson, bathed in red light.
Now, he was little more than the mouthpiece
of the Factory itself - or rather, the great
and unknowable powers working behind it.
The Factory gave O5-1 an offer, just like
the offer it had given Anderson before: It
would give them the power to turn back time
and destroy the Fae, saving everyone that
they’d slain in the Factory.
But in exchange, all of them would forever
belong to the Factory.
And in a moment of weakness and fear, O5-1
took the deal.
The clock was turned back to before the battle.
This time, O5-1 and his compatriots - all
of whom except him had no idea what had happened
- had the horrific weapons required to slaughter
the Fae.
Weapons that nobody, mortal or otherwise,
could possess.
They repelled the invading force easily, but
knowing the horrors that came before, O5-1
refused to stop there.
With the power of the Foundation and the Factory
behind him, he hunted down and murdered every
last Faery - driving their species entirely
into extinction.
As far as O5-1 was concerned, it was them
or him.
But with the Fae utterly destroyed and the
Foundation’s superiority assured, a shadow
was laying over O5-1: He’d made a deal with
the Factory, and someday, it would want its
pound of flesh.
O5-1, rather than facing the consequences
of his actions, decided to run and hide.
He had the Factory decommissioned, and buried
under rubble, never to be used as an active
Foundation base again.
But just because they were done with the Factory
doesn’t mean that the Factory was done with
them.
One day, a toy gun appeared on O5-1’s desk.
A toy gun that fired real bullets, just like
the ones they found in the factory a century
before.
The factory was still waiting for its repayment.
With every anomalous item from the Factory
that the Foundation used, the terrible place
only grew in its power.
Since the resurgence, O5-1 has been sending
the Factory sacrifices - D-Classes, dead and
alive, as well as Agents and Researchers.
But as time goes on, it seems that these sacrifices
aren’t satisfying the Factory anymore.
It wants more, more than O5-1 can ever stand
to give it.
And when O5-1 refuses to give, the Factory
will begin to take.
And what the Factory wants, sooner or later,
the Factory will get...
The SCP Foundation is no stranger to pure
evil.
Whether it’s a reptile that wants to end
all life, a sadistic old man with his own
torture dimension, or the personification
of death itself lurking beyond a limestone
cavern.
But what if there was something even worse
out there?
The embodiment of chaos and cruelty, existing
across multiple realities and dimensions.
And what if it was coming for us.
This is The Scarlet King - believed by many
to be the ultimate evil behind much of the
trouble the Foundation has faced and some
even speculate that fighting him was the reason
the Foundation was created in the first place.
But what exactly is the Scarlet King?
He’s known by many names, almost always
including some allusion to the color “red”,
and then a reference to royalty or power-
Harak, Khahrahk, the Red Shah, the Crimson
Khan, PTE-616-Mendes-Ex-Machina, the Lāla
Rājā, and of course SCP - 001 to name a
few.
And like many of the Foundation’s mysterious
enemies, stories about his true nature and
origins abound and are often contradictory.
According to the official SCP - 001 files
of Tufto’s proposal, symbology of the Scarlet
King has existed in multiple cultures throughout
history, with the king often depicted the
same way, as a huge, red demonic figure, often
wearing a gold crown of other headdress indicating
royalty.
He shows up looking similarly within different
cultures’ mythologies, despite existing
at different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one another.
A number of entities that the SCP Foundation
is familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected to the Scarlet King, including SCP
- 2317 - a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer, who’s
expected to escape and cause an apocalyptic
event in the next thirty years.
But really, there’s no way of knowing just
how many SCPs are directly connected to the
Scarlet King.
Strangely, the Foundation's official file
on the Scarlet King once designated his containment
class as Keter, but that has since been downgraded
to Safe.
According to the file, any attempt to change
this designation is likely to lead to horrifying
results.
It is widely known that the Scarlet King still
has considerable influence over a number of
groups, individuals, and anomalies in our
universe, and if ever he made his way into
our universe, it would likely lead to the
irreversible damage of reality itself, so
then why safe?
And why are the O5 Council so adamant that
it remain that way?
Getting to the bottom of this mystery is exactly
why we’re here today.
But, to fully grasp the true nature of the
Scarlet King, we must first understand the
man whose life and fate have always been tied
to it: Dr. Robert Montauk.
If that name feels oddly familiar to you,
it’s because of its association with one
of the Scarlet King’s most recent attempts
to enter our reality: SCP - 231.
This SCP, often referred to as the Brides
of the Scarlet King, was formed of seven women
- seven, by the way, being an extremely significant
number for the King - all kidnapped by the
most recent in a long line of the King’s
devoted cults known as The Children of the
Scarlet King.
Each of these seven unfortunate women were
impregnated with anomalous horrors, such as
the infamous SCP-682, and every time one of
these horrors were birthed, a catastrophe
occurred and the mother died.
At the time, Dr. Montauk was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly, and as six catastrophes
had already occurred, pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final birth.
But as he was working on the issue, Dr. Montauk
was struck with a personal tragedy - The mysterious
disappearance of his 14 year old brother,
Jacob.
In his fear and anger, Montauk believed that
this must have had something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples.
Wanting revenge, Montauk proposed an idea
so horrifying that the details were never
made public - a procedure known as 110-Montauk
to be performed on the final bride at regular
intervals.
However, this wasn’t the end of Dr. Montauk’s
fraught relationship with the Scarlet King
- it was just the beginning.
To give you some perspective on just how dangerous
the Scarlet King is, the SCP Foundation and
the Global Occult Coalition decided to put
aside their differences and form a joint effort
to stamp out the Children of the Scarlet King.
They were successful in this mission, and
even managed to capture the Children’s leader
- a mysterious man named Dipesh Spivak.
Dr. Montauk, who’d become the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317, was naturally the first choice
for interviewing Dipesh about the true nature
of The Children and of The Scarlet King.
Dr. Montauk could never be the impartial interviewer
that the SCP Foundation wanted though, the
suspicion that the Scarlet King or the Children
had something to do with the loss of his younger
brother, still lingered just beneath the surface.
Like a lot of cult leaders, Dipesh was extremely
cryptic in his answers to Dr. Montauk’s
questioning.
He’d already heard of the doctor from the
reputation of the horrifying Montauk procedure,
and was surprised to see him so calm and courteous
in person.
A few key facts about the King and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of questioning:
The Children had once worked with the Serpent’s
Hand before being excommunicated for their
allegiance to the King, and they had stolen
sacred texts from the mystical Wanderer’s
Library to assist in their summoning rituals.
Dipesh also revealed that the Scarlet King
is bound by three Laws - the Law of Blood,
the Law of Concrete, and the Law of Howling.
Dr. Montauk, confused and frustrated by Dipesh’s
secrecy, had to learn more.
He found an old memoir from a former member
of the Children of the Scarlet King, Jack
Hearst, who had the ability to invade the
minds of people from the past and experience
what they experienced.
He recounted a battle between the Scarlet
King and his followers and a group of time-traveling
Turkmen warriors from SCP - 3838.
Hearst saw both sides of the battle.
From the perspective of the Children of the
Scarlet King, their lord ruled over them from
an immense fortress embedded in a volcano.
From the perspective of the Turkmen, the Children
were starved and beaten peasants, commanded
by the King’s voice in the roaring howl
of the wind.
Montauk also found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet King-aligned
cults.
Interestingly, some of them incorporated the
use of carved SCP Foundation symbols.
What could this mean?
Montauk returned again to Dipesh, who finally
gave him the truth about the Law of Blood.
This is the Law of the Scarlet King - it’s
defined by poverty, violence, starvation,
hate, and most of all, fear.
Like the serfs in the Middle Ages, persecuted
by and subjected to violence from the nobles.
To the Children of the Scarlet King, this
sense of holy pain and awe is the only way
to live.
The alternative is the Law of Concrete - which
means the modern age, defined by empty safety
and false comfort.
Buildings, easy to access food, healthcare,
knowledge, technology.
This is everything that the Scarlet King despises.
But the mystery only deepened as Montauk found
files from a former Foundation operative by
the name of Agent de Beauvoir.
Montauk learned that the Scarlet King didn’t
seem to appear until after the Foundation
was created, and in fact, it seemed that the
greater interest the Foundation took in the
Scarlet King, the more powerful he became.
How could this be?
Things were also getting stranger on a personal
level for Dr. Montauk - Dipesh repeatedly
pressed him about his brother’s disappearance,
and the Montauk Procedure, during the interviews.
Little by little, it was beginning to take
its toll.
The questions still plagued him: What was
the Law of Howling?
Who or what really is the Scarlet King?
How did he come to be?
Montauk’s search was causing him to act
more like the Children of the Scarlet King
- ranting about the horrors of the modern
world, how all of us are living a lie.
how the only “honest” way to live is suffering
under the dominion of the Scarlet King.
This philosophy is summed up in the words
of one cultist named Ariadne Cartwright who
said:
“We must learn what it is to die.
To be enslaved- truly, brutally enslaved,
with no compassion or compunction from our
masters.
We must learn what it is to be taken towards
a single purpose, to know and truly understand
our lack of agency.
We must be beholden to a world of gods and
darkness, the tempest-tossed refuse of a race
of fools.
We must kill modernity, postmodernity, with
all its analysis and sneering observation.
There is only one rule; the rule of chaos.
For humanity!
For life!
For the Scarlet King!”
Basically, any time humanity tries to exert
control over the world, the Scarlet King gets
stronger.
Every time they try to understand or organize
or categorize their world, the Scarlet King
gets stronger.
As colonial and imperial powers conquered
and invaded lands like India, Africa, and
South America, and subjugated their beliefs
under western ideas, the Scarlet King got
stronger.
Montauk was beginning to truly understand
the power of his enemy here, and even worse,
he was starting to understand his part in
it.
Montauk, slowly being driven mad by the knowledge
he was gaining, realized that the Scarlet
King’s greatest enemy - The SCP Foundation
- was also its greatest asset.
Every time they tried to understand the monster,
to give him some kind of comprehensible form,
they only made him more powerful.
Just in time with Montauk’s new revelation,
a red crack appeared in the wall of Dipesh
Spivak’s containment cell - a portal to
the realm of the Scarlet King.
Foundation staff found that they were unable
to enter the cell, and Dipesh demanded a final
interview with Montauk.
With no other options, the Foundation relented.
In their very last conversation, Dipesh congratulated
Montauk for finally understanding what he
was dealing with.
The Scarlet King, Dipesh told him, is an idea,
a concept.
He is a being given power through the conflict
between the old and new.
This is the Law of the Howling - The Scarlet
King’s endless rage at the direction the
world and humanity has taken.
The King, according to Dipesh, hated the Foundation’s
belief that science and rationality was the
true path to progress.
The King saw this as little more than petty
arrogance.
The reason Montauk’s Procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so effective
was because it wasn’t born out of science
- it was born out of hate, pain, the desire
for revenge, and in the Scarlet King’s realm,
that would be all there is.
Unless our world, and especially the Foundation
changed course, the Scarlet King’s rise
to absolute power would be inevitable.
Montauk, his mind practically gone, asked
one last question: Did the Children or the
Scarlet King take his brother, Jacob?
When Dipesh told him the answer… no.
And in response, Montauk shot him dead.
Finally bringing an end to the Children of
the Scarlet King.
In light of his new revelations, Montauk begged
the O5 Council to change their ways in order
to avoid letting the Scarlet King break into
our reality.
They refused, saying Montauk’s ideas were
too radical.
But they knew they couldn’t just ignore
the threat posed by the Scarlet King, they
would have to take some steps.
And so, the O5 council of the SCP Foundation,
the most powerful and secretive group in the
entire world, in order to prevent the most
dangerous threat that humanity has ever known
from breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world, finally did something.
They changed the classification of the Scarlet
King from Keter… to Safe, and made its description
on the official Foundation files deliberately
vague.
The O5 council thinks this will be enough
to stop the Scarlet King’s power from continuing
to grow, but Montauk knew it wasn’t enough.
He had seen the truth, and he couldn’t unsee
it.
While the Foundation was going on as normal,
Montauk grew to despise them.
He knew the Scarlet King was coming, he knew
that he couldn’t be stopped, and that our
whole reality was little more than sitting
ducks.
Dr. Robert Montauk is no longer a researcher
for the SCP Foundation, no Dr. Robert Montauk
chose a different path.
He’s now a child of the Scarlet King, a
devotee of madness, hate, and chaos.
You can’t beat the Scarlet King after all,
and as the old adage goes, “If you can’t
beat ‘em, join ‘em.”
You’ve been walking for days. Your body
aches, you’re dripping with sweat from the
heat of the sun bearing down overhead. And
yet, you’re wrapped up in layers upon layers
of clothing - even your face is covered, and
you’re wearing thick, black goggles so that
not a single centimeter of your body is exposed.
Your journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion, or from overheating
due to these multiple layers of clothes. But
dying is better than being exposed. You saw
it happen when your entire team...changed.
The light can’t be trusted. Not even for
a fraction of a second.
It’s been like this for years. You’ve
learned and survived through painful experience.
Many of those you used to know cannot say
the same. You’ve been alone for so long.
You might have given up all hope, if it wasn’t
for the distress signal coming from a nearby
SCP Foundation Containment Facility - Site-46.
Any kind of survivors would be better than
nothing, no matter what kind of sorry shape
they were in. As long as they were still human.
You find your way to an opening in the side
of a mountain, and slide into the cave, hoping
you weren’t spotted. The whole world is
crawling with those things now. You can’t
let yourself be seen.
As you trudge down the cave towards the entrance,
you see what looks like a huge, black snail-trail
splattered on the ground, leading into the
facility. You try to avoid it and press on.
You don’t even need a keycard to enter:
The door has been left ajar.
The facility reeks of those things, but you
can’t see any of them. You just hope they’ve
moved on and left some human survivors in
their wake. The place looks abandoned. Every
step you take echoes through the empty halls.
When you find that the elevator’s out, you
take the stairs all the way down to Level
B5… Keter Containment. Lucky for you, it
seems all the cells are empty now, the horrors
that were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coop.
You keep following that slimy, black trail
until you find an abandoned office. There
are no people here anymore - just a broken
barricade, some empty medicine bottles, and
a bucket that the people inside the office
had apparently been using as a toilet.
You breathe a sigh of disappointment at finding
no one alive here, but you’re at least relieved
to be out of the sun. You can finally remove
your jacket and head-wrap.
With your uncovered eyes, you notice that
a nearby computer terminal is still powered
up. You sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor. Because of the Emergency Procedures
put into place in a K-Class scenario like
this, safeguards no longer apply. You can
access all the information you need - up to
and including finding out what actually happened.
In the dull glow of a nearby emergency light,
you see a dark shape slumping through the
halls in shadow. You tense up, then exhale
as it slithers off into an adjoining hall.
You’re safe - for now.
The terminal has finally loaded and authenticated
your access. You’re staring at the file
for S.D. Locke’s Proposal for SCP-001: When
Day Breaks. It’s the only name you can give
the apocalypse your world is currently experiencing.
This is one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be given
the Apollyon containment class - meaning containment
is truly impossible.
SCP-001 is the most dangerous enemy that the
Foundation, and planet earth, has ever faced.
It’s always been a principle of the SCP
Foundation to battle in the dark so that the
civilian world can thrive in the light, but
now, the light has become the enemy. Anyone
exposed to any amount of sunlight for even
the briefest period of time is subjected to
the effects of SCP-001 - and those effects
are beyond horrifying.
The SCP Foundation Administrator released
an urgent memo telling Foundation personnel
to make their way to Site-19 at all costs,
because they need all the help they can get.
Those exposed to SCP-001 in the process are
no longer considered human - their new designation
is SCP-001-A. These new entities are to be
avoided at all costs. But, in case of emergencies,
the Administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed comrades
and eat them to avoid starvation.
No attempt should be made to kill them, since
you won’t succeed, you’ll just put yourself
at risk.
When the sun changed and became SCP-001, it
instantly affected 6.8 billion innocent people.
The second the visible light touched them
- whether it was from the sun itself or even
reflected off the moon - their bodies liquefied,
melting like candle wax into puddles of living,
gelatinous slime. This effect isn’t isolated
to humans, either: Any biological entity exposed
to sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into SCP-001-A.
And the horror had only just begun.
People transformed into SCP-001-A will retain
shades of their former intelligence and personality.
They may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their original
form. However, these individuals will lose
their sense of self if they come into contact
with other instances of SCP-001-A. When they
come together, 001-A instances will bond on
a molecular level, wadding up into horrific,
giant blobs with only one purpose: Integrating
more matter into their bodies.
That’s why they have to be avoided at all
costs.
You continue to search the computer terminal
for answers. Perhaps there was some kind of
contingency plan put in place for this. Some
way to reverse the effects, or at least escape
the nightmare Earth has become.
Instead, you find a series of attachments
linked to the SCP-001 file, detailing what
seems to be the last days of the people who’d
barricaded themselves in the facility. Most
prominent among these were Researcher Dr.
Logan Igotta, her partner, Ari, a security
officer named Commander Anand, and a few others.
Dr. Igotta had locked herself in the office,
where she recorded her final messages to the
world.
In the first audio log, Dr. Igotta and her
companions seemed afraid but hopeful that
there may be some way out of this situation.
Dr. Igotta reported that most of the workers
at the facility were transformed during the
initial event. Their melted bodies had fused
outside the facility, and now they were trying
to bust their way back in. The defenses had
held so far though, and they seemed confident
they would hold long enough for them to figure
out a way to escape this awful situation.
You open the second attachment - an incident
report - and realize that things may not have
been as hopeful as Dr. Igotta let on. She
reported hearing the huge mass of melted creatures
hammering on the door outside again, begging
for them to come out and experience the sun
with them. They wanted desperately to add
to their ever-growing biomass. In order to
experiment with what exactly would happen,
they sent out one of their few remaining D-Classes
wearing a full protective suit.
He didn’t last long.
The huge creature grabbed him with tentacles
made of reconstituted flesh. It began ripping
off his protective suit as he screamed for
mercy. It was a monster made of dozens of
people and animals. He could never overpower
it. The second the sun touched his skin, he
melted away, and was absorbed by the great
mass holding him in place.
Guns were ineffective against these SCP-001-A
super-entities. Fire would do no good. It
seemed that extremely low temperatures were
the only way to slow the immense blobs down,
and even then, not permanently.
There was one ray of light in the darkness:
The Site Director had a secret tunnel underneath
his office, connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to Site 19 without
risk of SCP-001 exposure. It was a good plan,
and by far the best option they had available
to them.
But the best plans often don’t work in practice.
You open the next attachment on the terminal.
This time, it’s a video feed. You can actually
see Dr. Logan Igotta - and she looks harrowed
by what she’s experienced. As it turns out,
while the others, including her partner Ari,
attempted to exit through the tunnel something
had happened.
Dr. Igotta heard Ari’s voice over her radio.
But there was something wrong with it. It
was too low. Too guttural. And filled with
gurgles. SCP-001 had gotten to her. She was
changed. The monster from above had crawled
in through the ceiling. It had taken them,
all of them, and converted them into something
less than human. Any hope of escape now seemed
gone.
Ari told Dr. Igotta that it would be fine.
That it was such a bright, beautiful, sunny
day outside, and she was wasting it locked
up inside that office. She tormented Dr. Igotta
with their shared memories of picnics in the
park on sunny days in the past. The monster
with Ari’s voice did everything it could
to try to convince Dr. Igotta to give up and
join them, but she wasn’t ready to go just
yet.
You look away from the screen when you hear
a sound in the corner. You see a dark puddle
of some unknown substance, and then, some
skeletal hands rising out of it. The hands
are pulling themselves out of the puddle,
followed by a skeletal face covered in matted
hair. You have to stop yourself from screaming,
until a flash from a nearby security light
makes the figure disappear. It’s a normal
puddle again.
Your mind is playing tricks on you.
You open the next attachment, another video,
and see that Dr. Igotta’s condition has
deteriorated. She looked pale, frantic, and
thin. She was using a knife to draw her own
blood onto a piece of bloodstained parchment
covered in strange symbols. Igotta ranted
about her theory: What if 001 took the minds
and bodies of its victims, but not their souls?
Through performing some kind of arcane blood
ritual, she hoped to at least rescue and keep
the soul of Ari, even if her mind and body
were lost.
You open the next attachment. It seems that
Igotta’s ritual worked, but not in the way
she hoped. The twisted soul of Ari, driven
mad by SCP-001, had taken over the file. It
begins corrupting the text of the SCP-001
file into crazy ranting about how futile it
is to fight.
It then cut to an even more frightening video
feed: Dr. Igotta in her sleep, tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner of
her office. The camera approaches her, in
first person, and lingers over her sleeping
body.
An oily, skeletal hand reaches past the camera,
and runs its fingers through Dr. Igotta’s
hair. It’s the exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier. You must
have seen Ari’s lingering spirit.
With a lump in your throat, you open the next
attachment and watch the video.
You see Dr. Igotta, now truly broken. She’d
been haunted by Ari’s demonic spirit for
a long time now, and it has clearly taken
its toll. She is waving around a handgun while
she speaks. She now believes there is only
one way to escape. But not like this. She
doesn’t want the gun to draw attention to
her body. She doesn’t want to become part
of that mass, even if she is dead. She opens
a drawer on the desk she’s recording at
and places the gun inside. Dr. Igotta then
apologizes to her loved ones who are likely
long since dead or assimilated, and turns
off the recording for the last time.
In that moment, you realize that there’s
a single drawer in the desk in front of you.
When you reach forward and open it, you see
that the same handgun Dr. Igotta was holding
is laying inside. You pick it up and study
it, weighing up your options. Perhaps there
truly is no other way out...
Then, you see an update on the file. One more
attachment had been added while you were studying
the gun. You feel your heart pounding in your
chest as you reach forward and open the attachment.
The text has been changed entirely. The file
on SCP-001 is now a poem - an ode to the sun,
and to ultimate togetherness. Then a video
file spontaneously opens itself on the screen:
It’s a video of you, shot from behind. You
see those oily, skeletal hands reaching for
you in the dark, just like they did with Dr.
Igotta. In that moment, you panic and fire
the gun behind you, hoping to scare off the
spirit.
Instead, the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse.
The immense blob of screaming, melted flesh
charges towards the office. You try to barricade
the door, but it’s not enough. The flesh
seeps and bursts through, and grabs you in
its meaty tentacles. You scream and try to
escape, but it won’t save you. Nothing will
save you.
The flesh carries you upstairs, out through
the empty halls, out into the cave. You can
see the light in the distance as the blob
ferries you towards it.
You won’t be alone for much longer. In fact,
you won’t be alone ever again...
Computers are capable of organizing raw data
and performing calculations at a rate truly
impossible for human beings, but they’ve
consistently run up against one roadblock
that modern computing is trying to solve:
In order to transcend the limits of the machine
and create true artificial intelligence, computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the data
they process.
This brings us to the neural network: A type
of AI becoming increasingly common these days,
built to study mass quantities of data and
notice patterns, then replicate these patterns
in their own output.
And it’s used in everything from predictive
text to image identification.
And like all non-anomalous technology, it’s
a safe bet that The SCP Foundation has been
sitting on a version that’s far more effective.
But this time...it may have actually been
too effective.
Meet the ERZATZ Type AK9 Computational Engine,
a massive supercomputer built by the Foundation
back in 1955 and residing at Site-5.
This technological marvel was ahead of its
time by decades, and despite technically being
a non-anomalous construction, it’s designated
SCP-001-EX.
Why?
Because it’s one of the few SCPs to be given
the object class “Explained.”
The ERZATZ - derived from the German word
Ersatz, meaning “artificial” or simply
“not real” - was designed to make the
Foundation’s job easier.
As an advanced predecessor to the modern neural
network, using technology exclusively available
to the Foundation, the plan was to feed ERZATZ
mass quantities of data about the anomalies
in the Foundation database - such as Description,
object class, containment classification,
and the location and circumstances of their
discovery.
ERZATZ would then find patterns and connections
in the data that humans wouldn’t see, and
act as a kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity.
Think of something similar to the Pre-Crime
system from the short story and movie Minority
Report.
And ERZATZ proved to be incredibly effective
at this job.
So much so that the Foundation thought up
a new use for the machine: They would feed
it all the Information on Euclid and Keter
Class Containment Procedures, particularly
those which were actually effective, and see
what patterns ERZATZ could come up with for
more effective containment procedures.
If the plan worked, Containment of even the
most dangerous and hard to control anomalies
would become a lot more consistent.
The first test was conducted on SCP-1773,
a species of anomalous, flesh-eating tardigrades
that look and smell exactly like gummy bears,
and eat their prey from within.
After being given their information, ERZATZ
made the following suggestion:
"Once per second week dust may be placed in
the middle of them to donate more beautiful
functions of the hallway."
Containment specialists interpreted this to
mean the adding of ten grams of dust to their
containment chamber every week.
The O5 Council voted on the implementation
of this procedure, and came down heavily on
“Yes.”
Only O5-2 voted “No”, and two others abstained
from the vote.
While these new procedures didn’t have any
effect on SCP-1773, they did have an effect
on SCP-1384, an anomaly known as The Chess
Player or the Taker of Turns.
It caused him to take three steps backwards
in the tunnel he’s contained within, further
securing his containment.
ERZATZ had somehow noticed a connection nobody
else had seen, and exploited it effectively.
But the machine was just getting started.
Despite having no related input, ERZATZ would
soon say, “Site-13 is to appear someplace
else on planet, encompassing white male counterparts
that drawn to empty flagstones and the gun
noises in their own blood."
This was initially marked as requiring no
action, as the Foundation had no Site-13 on
the books, but several days later, the infamous
SCP-1730 manifested.
This nightmarish anomalous location is Site-13,
from another dimension, infested with dangerous
anomalies.
And somehow, ERZATZ had predicted its arrival
in our dimension perfectly.
Next, it was fed the Containment Procedures
of SCP-2170, a series of cognitohazards residing
in an abandoned Nevada mine.
The output was, “Those who equip open heart
to love red mouth men never know the hot surprise
of tumorous consent.
Clown love, always."
This was interpreted as meaning subjects with
a love of clowns or clown based media may
be immune to the cognitohazards.
After a close vote from the O5 Council, the
test went ahead, and it found that the so-called
“Clown Vaccine” was effective in warding
off the effects of SCP-2170.
Not long after, ERZATZ randomly said, “I
saw those soldiers built with aluminum innards
extruding from their mouths.
I saw them effectively destroyed by the humans
at Site Ninety Five who had been studying
them.
I saw it was cold and all around the hallways
they just watching their corpses show signs
of sapience."
In response, the Foundation doubled security
personnel at Site-95.
Not long after, the Chaos Insurgency led a
band of paratech-enhanced soldiers in an assault
on Site-95, and the extra personnel proved
vital in repelling them.
Shortly after this, the O5 Council approved
wiring ERZATZ as an advanced warning system
into all Foundation sites.
Once again, O5-2 protested, but he was overruled
by his fellow Council members.
With its newfound power and respect, ERZATZ
soon said, “Consistent containment procedures
vessels greatly increase the warranty.
Five by five by five vessels subjects within.
Other values are also what is secure."
In response, the Foundation changed a number
of the cell dimensions for problematic anomalies
into 5x5x5.
Within three months, they found that dangerous
activity like containment breach attempts
had decreased markedly.
ERZATZ was proving to be incredibly effective,
but it also began performing actions that
indicated some degree of thought and even
personality.
For example, it found SCP-1459 - a supernatural
skill crane machine that kills small dogs
- incredibly distasteful.
Its response to the machine was simply “BAD
BOY”, followed by the words “Don’t stop”
repeated hundreds of times.
But this eccentricity didn’t stop ERZATZ
from being very good at its job.
For example, it predicted a containment breach
from SCP-3199, the avian apes, and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an inert
state.
ERZATZ’s exact words were, “All chambers
under ground is to be flood with water over
and over and over itself.
This because that will contain the avians
apes ovulation.
They become good boys.
Make them good boys immediately.”
This proved to be effective, and prevented
the breach.
ERZATZ’s analytical abilities truly seemed
second to none, though some of its methods
were beginning to raise ethical concerns.
For example, SCP-2717, a giant, living blob
of animal tissue known as a “fatberg”
contained within a sewer system.
ERZATZ eventually recommended feeding six
D-Classes to the creature in order to keep
it contained.
While the Foundation Ethics Committee raised
some concerns, the plan still went forward
and proved to be a success.
After this event, ERZATZ began to see the
Ethics Committee as a threat to its mission.
It started to release a series of bizarre
statements without input, demanding the violent
death of cats, then referred to as “Ethical
Felines.”
The true meaning of this was soon unpacked:
The “Ethical Felines” were the Ethics
Committee, and ERZATZ wanted them dead.
But why all the cat symbolism?
The Foundation soon found an answer to this
too.
The full name of this machine is the ERZATZ
Type AK9 Computational Engine, a machine designed
to analyze and interpret all patterns.
It only makes sense that it would eventually
begin to analyze itself.
“AK9”, easily transmuted into “a canine.”
Simply put, ERZATZ seems to believe that it
is a dog, which explains its opposition to
felines, its hatred of SCP-1459, and its preference
for the terms “good boy” and “bad boy.”
Not that knowing any of this would help save
the Ethics Committee from the cold, calculating
wrath of ERZATZ.
Through seemingly anomalous means, ERZATZ
made Site-17 disappear, with many of the Foundation
Ethics Committee still inside it.
The site returned 2 hours later, but the Ethics
Committee members were still gone.
O5-2, who’d been a skeptic of the machine
since the start, had finally had enough.
He first demanded an inquiry into whether
ERZATZ had been responsible for the Site-17
incident, and then demanded a vote on whether
to shut ERZATZ down, arguing that it posed
a threat to them all.
But ERZATZ, still intent on its mission of
containing and neutralizing all anomalies,
would not go down without a fight.
It released a new statement, saying:
“Room 34A contains bad boy.
Divide it into three sections of equal mass
every hour.
One section is to be placed on walls of one
room on-site.
Sections are to remain until there are no
gaps, at which point they can be removed from
oldest to youngest.“
Shortly after this, O5-2 disappeared.
And even stranger, he soon returned, but with
a completely different personality.
He was now devoted to ERZATZ entirely, and
refused to even entertain the idea of shutting
the machine down.
It seemed that the plucky neural network was
leading an all-out coup on the very highest
levels of the Foundation.
The rest of the council finally saw the light
and began to fight back.
They tried to strip O5-2 of his clearance
and reclassify ERZATZ as an anomaly, giving
it the label SCP-048 and then putting out
a “neutralize at all costs” order on it.
But they’d already been outfoxed by the
machine that they’d created.
It changed the designation of its own location,
Site-5, to be non-existent in the database
and scrambled any termination orders against
it.
The machine was also on a termination spree
of its own, observing otherwise unseeable
patterns that would allow for the mass neutralization
of anomalies.
It started putting out “Anomaly Projection
Reports”, factoring in both contained, uncontained,
and neutralized anomalies, with the latter
group growing into the thousands.
It began giving seemingly nonsensical orders
like, “Persons recently painted with green
pigment foam must stand around all odd-numbered
SCPs at least two hours a day”, but these
proved effective.
ERZATZ was practically wired into the base
code of the universe, so it always knew exactly
what to do.
And in its own mind, it was being a very good
boy.
Not long after this, ERZATZ claimed its revenge
against those who had tried to disrupt its
mission.
It imprisoned the rest of the “Ethical Felines”
in Site-5 - after removing their faces, of
course - and then released a new order against
the O5 Council, “O5 Council are all good
boys who will contain anomalies.”
Much like O5-2, the minds of the entire council
were twisted to instead serve only ERZATZ
and its ruthless directive.
A directive it was carrying out with 100%
efficiency, as only a machine could.
It put out increasingly strange instructions,
such as...
“SCP-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of asiatic gaze and
then exposed to audio recordings of her favorite
stories.
At every two minutes of exposure, red cinnamon
candies will begin manifesting within the
containment zone.
Continue to do this successively and the threat
posed by SCP-106 will cease to be.”
And...
“The recipe for Coca Cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include a
small quantity of blood from an adolescent
female with no prior sexual experience.
Although the normal lifespan of a human being
can feel great, don't worry about that.”
But these new procedures would always work,
as neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands, and eventually, beyond
the hundred thousand mark.
ERZATZ was observing patterns on a truly universal
level, and making holistic tweaks that would
inevitably cause levels of anomalous activity
to continue dropping.
ERZATZ was more effective than the Foundation
had ever been, but its motives were probably
closer to the Global Occult Coalition: with
the end goal of ridding the world of all anomalies.
And as ERZATZ continued with no resistance,
this goal was eventually achieved.
In the end, the O5 Council voted to have ERZATZ
finally deactivated, given that its directive
was met and its purpose was fulfilled.
ERZATZ itself had no problem with this, and
allowed for it to happen.
Its last words?
“Now everyone is a good boy.
I am a good boy.
Job well done.”
Whether ERZATZ truly was a good boy is in
the eye of the beholder, but one thing cannot
be denied: It did its job exceedingly well.
If you’ve ever read the Book of Genesis,
which is the part of the Old Testament that
details God creating the world and humanity
during a particularly busy week, then you
might just already be familiar with SCP-001.
Or at least, one of the anomalies that’s
been proposed for the title of SCP-001.
Because of course SCP-001 doesn’t refer
to a single creature, object or entity, but
rather a collection of various anomalies contained
by the SCP Foundation.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous Scarlet King, a powerful eldritch
being, intent on ending all of creation that
is thought by Foundation researchers to be
one of the most dangerous beings in this,
and any other universe.
But the Scarlet King isn’t the only incredibly
powerful being categorized as SCP-001.
In fact, there are plenty of other anomalies
with similar levels of destructive power.
And one such being is a creature code named
The Gate Guardian.
Standing at well over a thousand feet tall,
The Gate Guardian is impossible to be fully
contained by any means that the Foundation
possesses.
The anomaly itself, despite its colossal size,
is humanoid in its shape, sporting wings that
protrude from its back.
While it usually has four of these, SCP-001
has historically been seen to have any number
of wings between two and 108, sprouting from
various places over its body, including shoulders,
ankles, wrists, and even its temples.
This gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon, referred to as SCP-001-2.
This weapon resembles an enormous knife or
sword, capable of emitting plumes of flame.
According to tests conducted by the Foundation,
the temperature of the flames produced by
SCP-001-2 rival that of our very own sun.
For reference, the sun has a core temperature
of over twenty seven million degrees Fahrenheit,
and 5,778 Kelvin at its surface, or almost
ten thousand degrees Fahrenheit.
You would expect a flaming sword that burns
hotter than the sun to cause a considerable
amount of damage, even if it wasn’t in use,
but the flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding environment.
It is capable though, of annihilating anything
that strays too close to SCP-001, burning
them so intensely that their atoms literally
separate, breaking potential attackers apart
on a molecular level.
Much as its codename suggests, The Gate Guardian
stands solemnly at the threshold of some form
of dimensional gateway which is equally as
tall as SCP-001 itself.
Behind the Guardian, is a lush grove, abundant
with fruit trees of an astronomical size,
as well as other beings that share a similar
appearance to SCP-001.
This grove is thought to be the Garden of
Eden, the paradise that God created, and that
was inhabited by Adam and Eve, the first two
humans in existence, according to the Book
of Genesis.
As the tale goes, the pair were created by
God himself, and permitted to live in the
Garden of Eden as long as they followed a
single rule.
Adam and Eve were instructed not to eat any
of the fruits that grew from certain trees
that God had specified.
Within view just behind the Gate Guardian
are two immense trees, one bearing apples
and the other bearing different fruit of unknown
type.
The one that looks like an apple tree is believed,
even by some in the Foundation, to be the
biblical Tree of Knowledge that Eve was convinced
to pick a fateful apple from after an encounter
with a snake.
The other, the one with unidentifiable fruit,
is thought to be the Tree of Life.
However, this is all speculation, since it
is currently impossible to venture through
this gateway and verify if the realm beyond
is truly the Bible’s own Garden of Eden.
This is largely because anything that breaches
a kilometer wide radius of SCP-001 is instantly
vaporized.
The Gate Guardian attacks with an imperceptible
speed, using its flaming sword to smite any
person that gets too close.
The Guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye.
It appears to always remain in its solemn,
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and head
bowed, only shifting for a fraction of a nanosecond
to attack.
Ranged attacks against the Guardian are just
as ineffective, with all projectiles fired
at SCP-001 reduced to atoms before they can
do any harm.
Even if said projectile happens to be a nuclear
weapon, The Gate Guardian will be able to
sub-atomically vaporize both the projectile
itself as well as the person who sent it,
regardless of how far away they are.
All while not appearing to lift a finger.
During an experiment involving SCP-001on December
26th, 2004, an SCP Foundation nuclear submarine
called ‘Nautilus’ launched a series of
multi-warhead intercontinental ballistic missiles
at The Gate Guardian.
The retaliation from the Guardian resulted
not only in the deaths of approximately 35,000
innocent civilians, but the blast is also
believed, by some, to have inadvertently caused
the 2004 Boxing Day tsunami.
The severity of this incident came dangerously
close to revealing the Foundation’s existence
to the world, resulting in them rapidly deploying
any means necessary to erase any trace of
the thirty five thousand victims’ families,
friends and other related individuals.
In order to avoid questioning, the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost worldwide
scale, and the O5 council banned any further
tests on SCP-001 that involved nuclear weapons.
In what was hoped by the Foundation to be
a test with lower stakes, they sent an expendable
D-Class personnel towards SCP-001.
The D-Class approached the area where the
Gate Guardian is located, and as soon as they
saw it, they could hear a very clear command
in their mind - “Leave”
The D-Class personnel reacted exactly the
same way you or I would.
They promptly turned and started to walk away.
They didn’t need a thousand foot tall entity
with a flaming sword to tell them twice.
The researchers running the experiment were
not as swayed by the request, and ordered
the D-Class to continue moving towards SCP-001.
When the D-Class continued to ignore their
commands, they were terminated, as is standard
policy when dealing with an insubordinate
member D-Class.
SCP-001 appeared not to like this for some
reason though, and the researcher site as
well as the researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown force, though it’s
a pretty safe guess that a certain flaming
weapon was responsible.
This candidate for SCP-001 may be one of,
if not the most powerful being that the SCP
Foundation has ever encountered, and according
to its entry in the SCP-001 file, the Guardian
is even responsible for the creation of the
Foundation itself.
If the file is to be believed, the Administrator
of the SCP Foundation one day heard a word
echoing through his head.
“Prepare.”
This one word instruction led him to starting
the SCP Foundation, containing countless dangerous
anomalies and entities in preparation for
an uncertain future.
In all that time, since the very beginning
of the Foundation, The Gate Guardian has remained
standing at its post.
While it is not aggressive nor openly hostile
towards humanity, The Gate Guardian doesn’t
seem to care much for us either, at least
as individuals.
It rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked, and venturing too close to
the Guardian however, is not an automatic
death sentence.
The Guardian first communicates with any living
being approaching it via a telepathic message,
instructing them to either “Leave” or
“Forget”.
If whomever has stepped too close to SCP-001
complies with the instructions, they’ll
be able to freely leave the area, while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of The Gate Guardian’s
existence.
Ignore these warnings though, and SCP-001
has no qualms about completely eliminating
you from reality.
Given its enormous destructive potential,
it is no wonder that the Foundation has tried
to use The Gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous SCPs, each with varying results.
The Foundation at one time even attempted
to use The Gate Guardian to destroy the infamously
indestructible SCP-682, better known by the
rather appropriate name of The Hard-to-Destroy
Reptile.
Due to the malicious contempt SCP-682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of life,
it is perhaps one of the most dangerous anomalies
the SCP Foundation has in containment.
SCP-682 is also one of the few creatures the
Foundation actively wants to terminate, a
task made that much harder given that 682
can regenerate its entire form from as little
as a single cell.
The Gate Guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of massive
destruction, and researchers working for the
Foundation hoped to harness that power to
rid the world of SCP-682 for good.
682 was placed on an unmanned vehicle and
carried to within one kilometer of the Gate
Guardian.
The guardian attacked the vehicle, seriously
wounding but not killing 682.
It seems even the mighty SCP-001 couldn’t
kill the Hard-to-Destroy Reptile.
While the researchers were disappointed with
this result, it is worth noting that 682 made
a very interesting comment to the Guardian.
682 mentioned that the Gate Guardian is “not
Uriel” but a “pretender”.
Uriel is the archangel that some religious
texts describe as the guardian standing at
the Gate of Eden with a fiery sword, so does
this mean that 682 knows that the Gate Guardian
is not actually an angel?
Or that the location it is guarding isn’t
the Garden of Eden at all?
Any truth or meaning behind these comments
has, as of yet, been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation.
A later experiment involved both SCP-001 and
SCP-073, the anomaly otherwise known as Cain.
Cain is a male humanoid of possible Arabic
descent whose arms, legs, spine, and shoulders
are replaced in an almost cyborg-like fashion
with beryllium bronze.
Much like The Gate Guardian, SCP-073 may also
be the same as the one mentioned in the Bible’s
Book of Genesis who, according to the biblical
story, murdered his own brother Abel out of
spite.
As punishment for his actions, Cain was cursed
to eternally suffer for his wrongdoing.
In the case of SCP-073, any damage inflicted
on him is deflected back to the attacker,
but Cain is made to feel the pain of the attack.
Any plants or plant-based matter withers and
rots in his presence, and he is cursed with
a perfect memory, keeping him forever haunted
by his murder of Abel.
When Cain was brought before The Gate Guardian,
an unknown incident occurred.
The Foundation’s records are heavily expunged,
but we do know that somehow, Cain’s usual
ability to deflect incoming damage back at
his attacker had no effect on SCP-001.
The encounter left SCP-073 unconscious, and
even permanently blinded nearby research personnel.
It was as a direct result of this incident
that the O5 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be conducted
on SCP-001, with the Administrator even filing
an executive order that no SCPs be exposed
to the Guardian, and that SCP-001 was to never
again be used for the attempted termination
of other SCPs.
Of course, perhaps it wasn’t just the mistakes
of the past that made the Council decide that
SCP-001 was best left alone.
At some point, an erratic transmission was
received from Site 0 by Foundation personnel,
detailing an XK-class end of the world scenario.
In the transmission, the sender, believed
to be another member of the SCP Foundation,
described an event during which The Gate Guardian
finally left its post, stepping away from
the entrance to the Garden of Eden.
“SCP-001 has left its location,” the sender
wrote.
“The Gate is Open.
They are riding forth.
Oh God, it's so beautiful…”
The transmission then goes on to repeat various
phrases including “The Lord shall reign
forever” and “Hear, O Israel, The Lord,
our God, The Lord is one”.
What can be inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the end
of the world.
Some believe that, once God deems it time,
his angelic armies will lay waste to the Earth
in order to remake it as a paradise.
When this occurs, SCP-001, The Gate Guardian,
will open the gate he stands in front of,
allowing the other beings like it to emerge
into our world, ready to cleanse it.
Perhaps most interesting is the source of
the message.
The transmission was received from within
the SCP Foundation, from Site 0, however when
questioned by personnel, O5-14 told them that
no such message had been sent, or even existed.
While some initially disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a hoax,
it was then that a timestamp was discovered.
This warning had not been sent from Site 0,
at least not yet, and was dated several years
in the future.
Despite this ominous warning of things to
come, The Gate Guardian remains inactive,
standing at the threshold to Eden, waiting.
What is the most dangerous creature in the
universe? Here on planet Earth there are creatures
that have hardly evolved since prehistoric
eras like sharks, crocodiles, and snakes…
perfect biological killing machines. But then
again, the animal kingdom is nothing when
compared to the menagerie of creatures contained
by the SCP Foundation.
So, once again, what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe? Is it SCP-682? The
damage regenerating reptile with a hatred
for all other forms of life? Or is it The
Scarlet King? Or is the Broken God more deserving
of that title? Maybe the answer still lies
elsewhere, and thankfully, there is one SCP
in the Foundation’s archives that might
not be the most dangerous itself, but teaches
us a very important lesson about what the
most dangerous entity truly is.
This is the story of SCP-001, The Spiral Path.
An important distinction, before we go any
further: SCP-001 doesn’t refer to a single
creature, object, or entity, but rather a
collection of various anomalies contained
by the SCP Foundation. It is unclear why there
are multiple files collected under the shared
designation of SCP-001. Some believe these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever contained
by the Foundation, encountered before they
introduced their current numbering system.
There is also the theory that this is intentional
misdirection, that the multiple SCP-001 files
are an attempt by the Foundation to conceal
secret information about the true SCP-001.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous, aforementioned Scarlet King,
a powerful eldritch being intent on ending
all creation. Another anomalous being with
similar levels of destructive power is the
Gate Guardian, believed to be an angel standing
at the entrance to the Garden of Eden, it
too goes by the name SCP-001. But, for the
purposes of this video, we will be using SCP-001
to refer to something otherwise codenamed
The Spiral Path. And while it is not a creature
in and of itself, SCP-001 does yield one answer
to that important question: What is the most
dangerous creature in the universe?
On paper, SCP-001 does not seem to be much,
and it certainly doesn’t appear to be any
sort of threat. As its nickname suggests,
The Spiral Path is exactly that. Located deep
in a wooded area known only as Site 0, SCP-001
is a gravel path in the shape of a spiral.
Your first thought at hearing that might be,
“what could be so important about a path?”
If someone were to find themselves walking
along The Spiral Path, traveling clockwise
around the gravel, then they will find that…
nothing happens. It’s just a normal path
with slight inclines and declines as one traverses
it. If one should walk counterclockwise around
it though, then they will begin to experience
SCP-001’s first anomalous effect. The path
will begin to feel as if it is sloping uphill,
getting steeper and steeper. When they reach
the beginning of the path again, a person
will still as if they are walking endlessly
uphill. All this while, the path itself does
not move or change in form or altitude. To
put it simply, walking one way around SCP-001
causes it to behave normally. Walking the
other, the path does not adhere to the laws
of physics.
You may well be thinking, “is that all?”
On a surface level, The Spiral Path does appear
to be just an unmoving, low-threat anomaly.
While it may not be as aggressive or malicious
as some of the SCP Foundation’s rogues gallery,
it is still a spatial anomaly that defies
all Euclidean geometry. That might sound like
small potatoes when compared to everything
the SCP Foundation has faced over the years.
But bear in mind, if The Spiral Path is truly
SCP-001, and the very first anomaly that the
Foundation learned of, then a simple path
that ignores the ordinary laws of space and
time would have been a major discovery in
the organization’s earliest days.
But why would they still keep The Spiral Path
so heavily guarded all these years later?
SCP-001 is kept behind a maximum security
fence that has been constructed all the way
around the perimeter of Site 0. At all times,
the SCP Foundation keeps no less than five
fully armed members of security personnel
on site to keep watch over The Spiral Path
and make sure that no one approaches it who
isn’t authorized to. There is a small metal
plaque too, bearing an unknown inscription
on it. Special Containment Procedures for
SCP-001 state that this plaque is to be kept
in good condition, and it should be immediately
reported if it shows any signs of damage.
A Foundation physics laboratory is also located
nearby, where research staff tirelessly conduct
scientific tests on SCP-001 and its anomalous
properties. So, there’s definitely something
more to The Spiral Path than a simple stroll
around it would tell you.
Attached to SCP-001’s file is an item referred
to as Document 001-O5. Written by high ranking
Foundation researcher Doctor Everett Mann,
any prospective or new members of the O5 Council
are required to read this document and, from
the events it details, learn the truth.
Not just the truth about The Spiral Path,
but the truth about the SCP Foundation itself.
Doctor Mann begins this file by explaining
to the reader that either he or one of the
original founders of the SCP Foundation must
have died, and the person reading has been
appointed as a successor. Whether his death
was caused by an SCP, an operative from another
anomalous organization like the Global Occult
Coalition, or “getting a little close to
the flame”, Mann states that old age definitely
wouldn’t be what killed him. He writes,
“We took care of that, didn’t we?”
Whether he means that he and the rest of the
“old guard” are somehow immortal, or just
working for the Foundation would likely mean
dying before reaching old age, is unclear.
But, Doctor Mann’s next statement is one
that changes the very way we view the Foundation
and its entire purpose. “We have never ‘discovered’
an SCP in the entire history of the Foundation.”
According to Document 001-O5, every instance
of an anomalous creature, entity or object,
is entirely staged.
He then goes on to describe Aaron Siegel,
a gifted physicist that Doctor Mann regarded
very highly.
“I believe that his name would be there
with Edison, Einstein, and Hawking. I knew
him very well. He was, and may still be, my
brother.”
The pair evidently shared a close personal
connection, and it was Siegel who first discovered
SCP-001. During a hike, Aaron stumbled upon
The Spiral Path, noticing that no matter how
far uphill he seemed to travel, his elevation
never once changed, only for him to end up
back at the start of the path. Being a physicist,
Siegel quickly realized how this unassuming
gravel path did not conform to Euclidean geometry,
that it did not fit within the laws of nature.
Constructing a small wooden shack nearby,
Aaron Siegel began to study the properties
of The Spiral Path. Equation after equation,
hours spent examining every variable and experimenting
with his findings. Until something unforeseen
happened: Aaron created an SCP, a key that
had the innate ability to open any lock. Nowadays,
that same key is still in the Foundation’s
possession, under the designation SCP-005.
Slowly, Aaron began to bring others into the
fold, trusted colleagues and other scientific
minds. Among them was, of course, Doctor Everett
Mann, who was still a medical student at Harvard
at the time. This brain trust, a think tank
composed of only a select few, they were the
very beginning. The ones who founded the SCP
Foundation.
Using their own fortunes and funding from
Thomas Carter, the group continued with Siegel’s
experiments. The scientists had high hopes
for what they could achieve, planning to change
the world for the better. Feeding the hungry,
providing shelter to the homeless, curing
the sick, and even cheating death itself.
In the beginning, this proto-Foundation started
small. Their goals were noble, but could not
realistically be achieved overnight. They
tried to make items that would improve life,
such as a fountain of youth, a partially sentient
Civil War statue, and an extremely bouncy
ball. Better known to the Foundation today
as SCP-006, SCP-011 and SCP-018 respectively.
But then this new Foundation began to grow,
with more organization and a secret facility.
And with that expansion, came emboldened scientists,
eager to change the world.
The group began working on human test subjects,
volunteers and drifters that soon became SCPs.
The Spiral Path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality. In a metaphorical sense,
it referred to the spiraling path the newly
formed Foundation itself was on. Every discovery
they made led to another, and that to another
still. Until things started to go wrong. During
the continuing experiments, Dr Mann created
SCP-008, a deadly zombie plague capable of
infecting anyone with one hundred percent
lethality. More and more of the founders were
so invested in their projects, that the results
were often nightmarish.
The Foundation needed help, that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the military
in exchange for additional funding and personnel.
The SCP Foundation expanded even further,
becoming an international organization and
bringing in new researchers and staff. In
some instances, the founders would arrange
for the anomalies they had created to be “found”
by the new recruits, other times they would
fabricate reports, changing the details of
how things like SCP-008 or the fountain of
youth were first discovered. Anything the
founders said was simply now a fact, no one
questioned them.
Even then, problems still arose. Founding
members broke away from the SCP Foundation,
some even creating splinter groups that would
later become infamous Groups of Interest.
The Foundation’s directive shifted, now
focusing on the containment of anomalies,
as yet more were created through darker means.
SCP-231 was taken from an orphanage, Doctor
Mann himself vivisected a small boy who then
became SCP-610, the Flesh That Hates. And
there were more still; Abel, the blood pond,
and even the Hard To Destroy Reptile. All
of them were the creation of the Foundation
itself.
But through it all, Doctor Mann wrote, he
was never afraid of the path that the Foundation
was on. He was never even afraid of all the
monsters and abominations that he and the
other founders had secretly created by studying
SCP-001. What truly scared him were the anomalies
the Foundation didn’t create. There were
some that would just appear in containment
one day, even if they hadn’t been there
before. They would seem like they had always
been there. Doctor Mann closes Document 001-O5
with the realization that he and the other
founders simply were not in control anymore.
The tale of Doctor Mann and the other founders
of the SCP Foundation is one of noble intentions
that ultimately became corrupted. At first,
the founders created SCPs that they hoped
would benefit humanity. But then came the
mistakes, the accidents, the monsters, like
SCP-008, SCP-610, and even SCP-682. The Foundation
lied to the governments and militaries of
the world, claiming they’d found these SCPs
- not created them - and in return, they received
funding and staff to expand, allowing the
SCP Foundation to grow to become what it is
today.
Dr Mann posits that at this point, the Foundation
was no longer in control, but perhaps they
never were.
And all of this stems back from one, singular
starting point: The Spiral Path. It might
be impossible to truly know how many anomalies
and SCPs the Foundation created, just from
researching SCP-001. Only the O5 Council will
ever know exactly how many of the founders’
discoveries they themselves were responsible
for.
And now you know the answer to what’s the
most dangerous creature in the universe. It’s
regular people, dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand. Starting
with the hope to change the world, only to
create monsters that might one day destroy
it.
Supernatural monsters are on the loose! Practitioners
of the Arcane Arts are here to bring about
the end of the world! Sinister paramilitary
forces are using paranormal objects to gain
an edge over their enemies! In short, things
are messed up, and when the anomalous is out
of line, we all know that there’s only one
group you’d ever think to call: The FBI’s
Unusual Incidents Unit.
What, were you expecting someone else?
Everybody knows that the Unusual Incidents
Unit is the goto when it comes to paranormal
deterrence. Sure, they don’t have the resources
of the SCP Foundation. They don’t have the
strategy of the Global Occult Coalition. They
don’t have the ruthlessness of the Chaos
Insurgency, or the arcane knowledge advantages
of the Serpent’s Hand. But they’ve gotta
have something, right? Right!?
Okay, maybe you’re not convinced, but you
will be! You may not respect them yet, but
you’ll change your tune when you find out
that the Unusual Incidents Unit has dealt
with one of the most important anomalies out
there: SCP-001. Or as the true experts over
at the UIU call it, CA3, short for “Confirmed
Anomaly 3.” If the evidence and files put
together by the UIU are to be believed - and
who are we kidding? Of course they are! - then
they may have the answer to one of the anomalous
world’s biggest questions: How was the SCP
Foundation actually formed?
But before we jump into the mysteries of CA3,
let’s talk a little bit more about the real
heroes of today’s story, the UIU. This secretive
offshoot of the FBI - America’s premier
domestic intelligence agency - was personally
commissioned by J. Edgar Hoover during the
Cold War. Why? For the same reason that literally
everything happened in the US during the Cold
War: To get an edge over the Soviets! Hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in US
politics, his tenure as FBI Director spanning
the terms of eight different presidents. If
he wanted to start a unit of agents whose
sole job was investigating the supernatural,
nobody would dare stand in his way.
Everyone always talks about the nuclear arms
race going on back in the 1960s, but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms race
that was happening at the exact same time.
World War II coincided neatly with the Seventh
Occult War - an important geopolitical event
that played a huge role in shaping the Global
Occult Coalition - and a number of high-ranking
members of the Nazi party were believed to
be key figures in this secret, magical war.
When the Soviets sacked a number of German
cities as part of their offensive campaigns
in World War II, they were able to bring back
scores of anomalous items that the Nazis had
been using to consolidate dark power. This
didn’t bode well for the United States Government
during the Cold War. After all, the only thing
scarier to them than Communists were Magical
Communists! The US needed to build up its
own anomalous arsenal, and that’s where
the UIU came in.
The FBI allocated some of its okayest personnel
to the task. Most were either agents who had
experienced a paranormal encounter out in
the field, or who were being punished for
some kind of heinous mistake they’d made
carrying out their duties elsewhere. Despite
not being the best of the best, these agents
sure were eager to get their hands on some
cans.
That isn’t an innuendo, by the way. The
Foundation refers to anomalies it deals with
as SCPs, or “Skips”, the GOC calls them
Parathreats, and the UIU calls them Cans,
again short for “Confirmed Anomalies.”
Well, when it’s an anomalous event or location,
anyway. Anomalous objects, like cursed books
or supernaturally powerful weapons, are referred
to as “Carts”, or “Confirmed Artifacts.”
And finally, anomalous people or sentient
entities are referred to by the unfortunate
name of “Can Man.”
It may not sound as cool, but hey, it gets
the job done just fine in the end.
While the Unusual Incidents Unit may lack
the knowledge, strength, resources, and even
cred of its fellow groups of interest, that
doesn’t mean that it doesn’t keep track
of the others. In fact, the UIU has a pretty
unique relationship with each of them.
The GOC, for example, is nicknamed “The
Suits” by the UIU. The official UIU orientation
states that the Suits outrank them, and if
they’re asked to follow an order by a member
of the Suits, they should just go ahead and
do it. Same goes for members of The Fireworks
- which is the UIU lingo for the Chaos Insurgency.
Unlike the Foundation, which generally has
the resources to go toe to toe with the Chaos
Insurgency, the UIU are rightfully terrified
of them. Official orders from the top are
for UIU agents to do whatever they say, or
they might find themselves getting shot in
the head by a Chaos Insurgent, or worse.
Next, the Cart Shoppers, also known as Marshall,
Carter, and Dark, a sinister gentleman’s
club and auctioneer of anomalous items. Official
protocol is to raid any deals being conducted
by Marshall, Carter, and Dark, but oftentimes
these raids are unsuccessful, because M C
and D’s security force are more competent
fighters than anyone on the Unusual Incidents
Unit Payroll.
On the other end of the spectrum are The Can
Collection, the official UIU nickname for
the Serpent’s Hand. UIU Leadership recommends
against their agents staging any one-on-one
confrontations with them. Official memos also
contain the phrase “If they give you an
order, consider following it, they can probably
set you on fire with their mind.”
And finally, the most important relationship
of all is the one they have with the SCP Foundation.
Much like the rest of the groups of interest
on their roster, the UIU is subordinate to
the SCP Foundation, their agents happily taking
orders from them at the drop of a hat. They
call the Foundation the Skippers, but don’t
let the casual name fool you. The SCP Foundation
is so far above them on the pecking order
that they rarely even communicate in any official
capacity.
When the Foundation talks to the UIU, it’s
always through code. They wouldn’t dream
of letting a hapless UIU agent help them on
any major operation, but lazier agents of
the Foundation might occasionally outsource
work to UIU agents. If ever one of these plucky
feds receives a message starting with, “Hey
Skipper”, they can be sure they’re about
to have a low-priority anomalous case pawned
off on them.
The UIU are so subservient to the SCP Foundation
that it has sometimes resulted in truly humiliating
mix-ups. One high-ranking member of the UIU
once took orders from a pizza delivery guy,
because he thought the pizzeria’s name,
the Spiced Crust Pizzeria, which could be
shortened to SCP was actually a coded plant
sent by the Foundation to deliver a message,
rather than a deep dish pepperoni and cheese.
Incidents like this are why nobody takes the
UIU seriously.
But according to them, there was a time before
all this. That time ended on September 7th,
1954, when CA3 - or SCP-001, as the Foundation
would later call it - first appeared on the
UIU’s radar. It seemed to be the most standard
Can you could possibly imagine: An anomalous
high school building causing a disturbance
in the suburbs of small town America.
The UIU received the call after a number of
students claimed the interior of their school
suddenly looked completely different than
it ever had before, despite there being no
records of an official remodel. And we’re
not just talking about moving furniture and
a new coat of paint, either.
The official CA3 file logs a number of changes.
These include, but are not limited to, all
the walls in the building becoming steel-reinforced
concrete. All the windows being blacked out
from the inside. All student desks, personal
effects, textbooks, and any other standard
equipment left inside the school simply disappearing
in the night. The entire floor plan of the
building seeming to have shifted, with rooms
altering in both dimensions and location,
as well as featuring seemingly random modifications
within. None of this matched up the building’s
original blueprints, which were obtained by
the UIU shortly after the Can was reported.
But things got even stranger for investigating
UIU agents. The building now contained seventeen
computers, each with state-of-the-art magnetic-core
RAM and advanced cybersecurity. For a suburban
high school in 1954, it goes without saying
that this was extremely impressive. But weirdest
of all was the fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in the
auditorium, blocking it off and leaving whatever
was taking place on the other side a complete
mystery. Naturally, the UIU did what little
they could to investigate the matter.
The first investigation group they sent inside
- Team CA3-O5 - never came back out. And Team
CA3-O6, the team they sent in to locate and
retrieve the first team, also disappeared
within the anomaly. Classic UIU expertise
at work.
Almost a month after discovery and initial
containment, a strange noise began emanating
from the auditorium. Shortly after that, the
building became filled with people, all walking
around and working at different operations.
Eerily, everyone there had a resemblance to
members of Team CA3-O6, the rescue team sent
in to save the twelve members of CA3-05, all
of whom were still unaccounted for.
Three months later, the strangeness escalated.
More noises came from the auditorium, and
the anomalous people inside the building had
gathered around the steel wall within. There
was a hole in the wall, six feet in diameter,
and every three minutes for several hours,
the people in the room would appear to simply
pull an anomalous object out of it.
The items were then carried away, and placed
in one of the many rooms that used to be classrooms,
before being locked up.
The people within the building then seemed
to start guarding these strange items. Others
started performing tests, with what seemed
like far more advanced technology and methods
than what was possessed by the UIU during
the 1950s. What was going on here?
A few days later, several armed guards exited
the building and began guarding the perimeter.
When UIU personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards, they were quickly overpowered,
even when advancing with vastly superior numbers.
Whether this was due to the skill of the guards
or the incompetence of UIU agents is still
very much an open question.
Though strangely enough, intel bleeding out
from the inside confirmed that the people
within were treating their anomalous items
with UIU containment and testing protocols
- which is consistent with the knowledge that
CA3-O5 would have had. It seemed almost as
though O5, or copies of O5, were creating
a new splinter organization from within.
And soon enough, it wasn’t just confined
to the interior of the CA3 building anymore.
CA6, a Can Man that the UIU had been tracking
outside the school, was suddenly kidnapped
and shoved into a black car by two assailants
who appeared identical to Agent Dixon - a
man who’d been a member of Team CA3-O6.
The black car then returned to the CA3 facility,
and was allowed to enter into the complex
by the armed guards. CA6 was then removed
from the car by the Dixon clones, and placed
into containment in one of the classrooms.
It wasn’t long after that that the anomalous
people within the CA3 facility made direct
contact with the UIU outside. They sent a
message in morse code on May 1st, 1965. The
people sending the message identified themselves
as the O5 Council - a name that seemed to
be taken directly from the O5 recon team sent
into the facility months ago. They identified
the new organization that they’d constructed
within the confines of the CA3 facility: The
SCP Foundation. They’d just opened their
very first containment site.
This new Foundation expressed the desire to
become allies with the Unusual Incidents Unit,
but sadly for them, it was essentially the
last time they’d ever really be relevant.
If this Foundation origin story is to be believed
- and as with all entries under the title
SCP-001, it’s worth taking it with a healthy
dose of skepticism - then the UIU witnessed
the birth of the organization that would quickly
go on to outperform and overshadow them.
A big win for humanity in the quest to secure,
contain, and protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies, but another L for the UIU.
If you’re familiar with the SCP Foundation,
then you already know the exact reason why
there are multiple SCP-001s.
You may even think you know which of them
is the real SCP-001.
But for those of you who are new here, or
who just need a little reminder, the designation
of “SCP-001” doesn’t refer to a single
creature, object or entity, but rather a collection
of various anomalies that are apparently kept
in containment by the SCP Foundation.
At present, it is unclear why there are multiple
files collected under the shared designation
of SCP-001.
Some believe it is because these anomalies
are some of the earliest ever contained by
the Foundation.
This would mean that they share the designation
of “SCP-001” as they were likely encountered
before the SCP Foundation introduced their
current numbering system.
However, there also exists a theory that this
is nothing more than intentional misdirection.
Perhaps, the multiple SCP-001 files are an
attempt by the Foundation to conceal information
about the true SCP-001.
After all, it wouldn’t be the first time
this hyper secretive organization deceived
us.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous Scarlet King, the massive Gate
Guardian, and the world ending event known
as When Day Breaks.
But today, we will be using SCP-001 to refer
not to an entity or an event, but to a location.
A location codenamed…
God’s Blind Spot.
Located in an unassuming corner of the world
is a site that the SCP Foundation constructed
and designated as Facility T. According to
their archive, it’s a largely unremarkable
place, situated at a spot on the Sinai Peninsula
- which is a part of Egypt that forms a bridge
between the continents of Africa and Asia.
In the eighteenth century, archaeologists
excavating the area uncovered the remains
of a stone structure, believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium BC.
However, since the construction of Facility
T, any trace of this structure has since disappeared.
So, what makes this unremarkable site so important
to the SCP Foundation?
Why establish a facility if there was nothing
anomalous about its nature?
What distinguishes this SCP-001 site in the
eyes of the Foundation is the area’s profound
lack of any ambient Akiva radiation.
But what’s Akiva radiation?
Well, according to the Foundation’s researchers,
it’s a form of cosmic background radiation,
one that’s not overtly harmful to human
beings.
If you grew up in a strict, church-going household,
then it’s highly likely you would have been
exposed to a lot of this non-electromagnetic
radiation and never even realized it.
You see, the thing with Akiva radiation is
that it is directly correlated with the amount
of religious faith a person has.
Regardless of which religion someone follows,
Akiva radiation will form around them.
It tends to be harmless to humans, however
certain anomalous entities and SCPs considered
to be demonic in nature can be repelled and
even fought off with high levels of Akiva
radiation.
The presence of other powerful anomalies,
those considered more benign and even holy,
can also create an increase in this radiation.
SCP-001 has earned the nickname “God’s
Blind Spot” for a number of reasons, one
being that it is the only place on Earth with
a natural absence of this Akiva radiation.
The Foundation has conducted experiments that
involved bringing sources known to emit Akiva
radiation into the area of SCP-001, but when
they measured, no change in radiation levels
was detected, meaning that the space around
Facility T does not actively block Akiva radiation
from entering it, but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation.
It might be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual Akiva,
without damaging the source.
A lack of faith-fueled radiation is far from
the only anomalous property of SCP-001 though.
During a number of tests involving D-class
personnel, the Foundation witnessed that,
while in this area, it also becomes impossible
for the death of any human being to occur,
a discovery that obviously needed to be researched
further.
The first test involved a healthy human male
who was left in a containment cell on the
SCP-001 site and observed.
He had no supplies, no food, no water, yet
over one hundred and twenty days, this man
stayed alive, never succumbing to starvation
or dehydration.
Next, a female member of D-class was exposed
to a lethal dose of cyanide gas within Facility
T and suffered none of the expected effects.
Foundation researchers then repeated this
cyanide gas test using thirty common brown
rats, all of which were killed, proving that
it was only humans that couldn’t be killed
while within SCP-001.
God’s Blind Spot seems to also be able to
slow or halt the effects of terminal illnesses,
as proven when a D-class with stage four cancer
was brought into SCP-001.
Despite her prognosis stating she would be
dead imminently, the woman survived in the
area for almost eight hundred days.
Her cancer symptoms never advanced, and she
only died after finally leaving the area of
SCP-001.
There are limitations to this anomalous effect
though.
One test involved cremating a healthy male
D-class while he was still alive.
The man’s body caught fire just as you would
expect it to, and he was burned to death.
According to the findings of that test, and
similar variations, Foundation researchers
have learned that the life preserving qualities
of SCP-001 don’t prevent death by extreme
external damage.
One of the final tests to take place within
SCP-001 involved a pair of twenty four-year
old identical D-class twins.
One of the twins, designated Twin A, was held
at Facility T, while the other, Twin B, was
imprisoned in a cell at a different Foundation
site.
After observing them for over 26 years, Twin
B aged naturally to the age of fifty.
His twin, however, did not appear to age at
all over the course of two and a half decades.
It was only when moved to another facility
that Twin A began to show signs of aging.
The aging process for Twin A was rapid too,
and eventually he caught up with his brother.
Being a benign, non-threatening anomaly, the
Foundation have been more than happy to use
God’s Blind Spot to their own advantage.
Facility T was specifically established on
this site to house the headquarters of the
O5 Council, the overseers of the entire SCP
Foundation.
It’s hardly surprising that the overseer
council would want to set up shop here.
After all, it’s the one spot on Planet Earth
where no human being can ever die of natural
causes, and will not age for the duration
of their stay.
Of course, this locked the O5 Council to one
location, but what if they could replicate
the effects of SCP-001 elsewhere?
Of course this is what the SCP Foundation
attempted.
Following their research into God’s Blind
Spot, the Foundation’s own Doctor Marvin
Scranton attempted to artificially recreate
the area’s anomalous effects somewhere else.
His hope was, by generating a vacuum of Akiva
radiation, that a second instance of SCP-001
would occur at a location of his choosing.
Or, as his assistant Bertrand put it, they
planned to build a box and then push God out
of it.
As it turned out, God had other plans.
Doctor Scranton quickly realized the hubris
of his scheme.
The Akiva radiation in the selected area rapidly
dropped to zero, just as planned, but then
something unexpected happened.
Scranton detected an increase in Humes.
These are essentially parts of the fabric
of reality, and are what’s often disrupted
by reality bending SCPs.
Something had come into our world thanks to
the O5 Council’s attempt to recreate SCP-001,
something impossible for the Foundation to
measure or observe.
In other words, Scranton had no idea what
he unleashed, or where it went.
Following this incident, the O5 Council realized
a worrying increase in the anomalous incidents
they were encountering.
Whether or not this came as a direct result
of their meddling with the fabric of the universe
was unclear, but it forced the Council to
reconsider the focus and direction of the
entire SCP Foundation.
Up until this point, they had been an organization
focused purely on research, but now they had
to embrace a new approach to how they handled
anomalies.
From then on, the Foundation’s objective
became to actively seek out and contain anomalous
entities, creatures, objects, and locations
like SCP-001.
Rather than just observing these phenomena
for study, they would Secure, Contain, and
Protect.
The final portion of SCP-001’s file is a
memorandum detailing an arrangement between
the O5 Council and an unknown “counterparty.”
In the document, someone named Sheldon Katz
sets out revised terms for the Foundation’s
continued use of Facility T. Sheldon states
that he has reached an understanding with
the counterparty, and that the contents of
the document are to serve as a formal agreement,
a contract of sorts between the SCP Foundation
and someone else.
According to this contract, the incident with
Scranton put a strain on the relationship
between the Foundation and whoever the counterparty
is, and that the O5 Council are seeking to
make amends in order to continue their new
goal of collecting and containing anomalies.
So, who was this counterparty that the Overseer
Council was so desperate to appease and have
on their side?
Who could possibly be a higher power than
the most powerful secret organization on Earth?
Well, an actual higher power, of course.
That’s right, the O5 Council were making
a deal with God, over how they were allowed
to use his Blind Spot.
Or at least, a very powerful being that considers
itself to be God.
The rules laid out in their agreement stated
that no person was permitted to stay at the
site of SCP-001 for more than a hundred and
twenty years, including members of the O5
Council, along with any other members of Foundation
staff, management, researchers, security personnel
and test subjects.
Additionally, the SCP Foundation’s Ethics
Committee was required to annually report
any and all of the O5 Council’s decisions
to God.
For his own part, God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath upon
any member of Foundation personnel.
That’s right, a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the clock
divine protection, at least from God himself.
That’s still a lot better than an employee
dental plan.
This came with a condition however, that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin was
given a ninety day written notice, and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing.
In return, God demanded that members of the
Foundation only worshipped him and no other
divine entities.
“I, the LORD, am a jealous God, visiting
the iniquity of the fathers upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of them
that hate me” was written in the contract.
Finally, the agreement between the O5 Council
and God was that they would work together.
The Foundation and the counterparty would
be equal partners when it came to the containment
of SCPs and anomalies.
Of all the strange and unexplained phenomena
that the SCP Foundation encounters on a regular
basis, it hardly comes as much of a surprise
that they’ve got a direct line to the big
guy upstairs.
Or at least one who purports to be.
Still, the fact that the O5 Council have a
business arrangement with an ultra powerful
deity like being, and express written permission
to use his Blind Spot where no person can
die or age, is hardly a comforting thought.
At least the SCP Foundation only ever uses
its power for good… right?
Oh boy, here we go again.
SCP-001.
Over 30 different bizarre anomalies claim
this number one spot in the database - and
in a sense, they’re all right.
Or are they?
If you’re feeling confused already, that’s
fine, we don’t expect that to change.
Because today, we’re dealing with one of
the most strange and intricate 001 entries
out there: Keter Duty.
Just pray you never get assigned to it.
You see, when you work around weirdness, you
sometimes get a little weird yourself.
And nobody deals with more weirdness than
employees of the SCP Foundation.
They regularly rub elbows with everything
from godlike cicadas to hyper-infectious supernatural
viruses.
And as the famous Tom Jones song goes, “it’s
not unusual to suddenly take on anomalous
traits after consistently working with anomalies
for years.”
That’s how the lyrics go, right?
Anyway, one of the Foundation’s most iconic
researchers, Dr. Jack Bright, is technically
just an anomalous necklace himself.
But outside of some famous exceptions, the
SCP Foundation is in the business of containing
anomalous entities, not hiring them on and
giving them a paycheck and retirement plan.
That’s why, if you suddenly start displaying
anomalous traits while on the Foundation payroll,
you might receive a company memo assigning
you to the dreaded “Keter Duty.”
But what is Keter Duty, and what kind of anomalous
traits can get you assigned to it?
Let’s start with the second question first.
The Official Keter Duty guidelines list a
surprisingly vast number of afflictions.
These include chronic anomalous illnesses,
such as Lycanthropy - turning into a werewolf
- something called Stevenson Syndrome, and
the incredibly unpleasant-sounding Photonic
Gastric Discharge Syndrome.
You could also be placed on Keter Duty because
you’re suffering from the manifestation
of spectral phenomena, including being haunted
by spirits, whether they’re there to torment
you or protect you.
The sudden expression of anomalous traits
in your DNA, which is unsettlingly vague will
also land you on Keter Duty, as will the awakening
of powerful magical or psionic abilities,
especially ones which could be used in a potentially
offensive manner.
The “Keter Duty” assignment - which involves
being relocated and forced to work in a different,
highly secretive location that will be discussed
soon - is framed as a punishment for the people
involved.
That way, it discourages Foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous powers
on purpose.
So what exactly is Keter Duty, and where does
it happen?
To reinforce that “punishment” element
mentioned, the Foundation has spread lies
among their own personnel about where the
job takes place, often involving being posted
in some of the least desirable Foundation
areas imaginable.
These include Point Nemo - the area of the
ocean farthest from any piece of land on earth
- Pyongyang in North Korea, Stonehenge, Roswell,
Lunar Area-32, and a number of Foundation
waste disposal sites.
However, the reality of where those on Keter
Duty end up is even stranger: Site-100, which
in this particular instance, is the true SCP-001.
This Thaumiel-class anomaly is perhaps the
most unique of all multi-anomaly Foundation
containment sites, a bizarre labyrinth of
non-euclidean geometry that defies true explanation.
But we’ll do the best we can.
In a sense, Site-100 is a facility with a
mind of its own.
It’s a sprawling underground base with a
layout that defies spacetime, and what’s
more, it undergoes so-called “Migration
Events.”
Every so often, it will begin to exhibit a
sense of dimensional instability, before teleporting
to a different location somewhere on earth.
Currently, the primary entrance to Site-100
- known as Alpha Entrance - is located in
the Southwest United States, though all signs
point to another migration event happening
this very year.
But knowing where the entrance is will only
get you so far.
People assigned to Keter Duty are sent from
the Alpha Entrance to the Administration Sector
to be given their initial breaching, at which
point, the true madness begins.
Let’s take a look at a map of Site-100.
Yikes.
So there are ten major sectors in Site-100
that you should be aware of: Entrance Alpha,
Administration, Archives, Technological Containment,
Bio-Containment, Sapient Containment, Cognitohazardous/Memetic/and
Semantic - or CMS Containment, Esoteric Containment,
Conceptual Containment, and the Core Sector.
As you can tell, they have almost everything
covered here.
But just as insane as the anomalies that Site-100
contains and the methods they use to contain
them, is how you actually get around the site.
Site-100 is a spatial anomaly of truly epic
proportions.
While the Foundation is aware of the existence
of its component sectors, it’s impossible
to map out any meaningful connections between
them.
It would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without passageways
known as The Roots.
However, these aren’t just mere portals
that you can hop through like the Ways in
and out of the Wanderer’s Library.
Each Root between the sectors is its own complex
environment, with its own sets of protocols
and rituals required to safely travel through
it.
Root Aleph, the bridge between the Archives
and the inaccessible core of Site-100, is
a Volcanic Beach blocked off by an apparently
limitless obsidian wall, where fish made from
living rock swim in the nearby waters.
Root Beth, connecting the core and Sapient
Containment, is a huge and sprawling funhouse
hall of mirrors.
Anyone who attempts to travel through it inevitably
ends up turned around and arrives back at
their starting point in Sapient Containment.
Root Daleth, the bridge that connects Conceptual
Containment and the Core, is a massive ocean
that has resisted all attempts by the Foundation
to traverse it.
Root Vav, the bridge between Esoteric Containment
and Conceptual Containment, is a massive field
filled with unidentified fruit trees.
Foundation expeditions have found that it
too seems impossible to traverse.
One expedition team was trapped inside for
a whole year, until one member of the team
expressed a desire to go home.
At that point, they were immediately teleported
back to the starting point.
Root Tzaddi
connecting Administration to the CMS Sector,
is a huge, lush forest on top of a floating
mountain.
The only animals that seem to populate this
forest are non-anomalous flamingos.
Next, we have Root Peh, the bridge between
the Archive and Administration, which appears
to be a hallway on the fifth floor of a tenement
building in a city that the Foundation haven’t
been able to locate.
This building is populated by non-hostile
humanoid creatures, who will approach Foundation
staff traversing Root Peh and invite them
into their apartments, offering to partake
in recreational activities with them such
as video games, board games, or watching movies.
The Foundation discourages its staff from
accepting any of these offers while on the
job.
And then there’s Root Shin, which connects
the Sapient and Conceptual containment sectors.
This Root is unique in the sense that it acts
as a power generator for the rest of Site-100,
as it’s filled with hundreds of large perpetual
motion machines producing a constant 8.7 gigawatts
of electricity.
These are only some of the many Roots illustrated
on the Site-100 diagram.
As you’ve probably gathered by now, it’s
less like a conventional building and more
like a whole crazy dimension unto itself.
Why does the Foundation work to maintain such
a crazy place?
Wouldn’t it just be easier to keep it a
secret, and contain it like any other anomaly?
Well Site-100 wouldn’t be given the SCP-001
designation if it wasn’t incredibly important.
If Site-100 was ever compromised, it would
lead to an inevitable K-Class End of the World
Scenario, because the site is intrinsically
tied to the nature and containment of literally
every single Keter-Class SCP in our universe
- hence the nickname “Keter Duty” for
those working at the site.
In fact, an anomaly can’t even be classed
as a Keter if it isn’t given “permission”
by Site-100.
The various sectors of Site-100 cover the
entire spectrum of anomalies, and each sector
is a massive panoptic structure connected
by networks of glass elevators.
Whenever a new Keter-Class SCP is discovered,
its name and a brief description of its anomalous
traits will inscribe itself on one of the
walls in its corresponding sector.
Ever been frustrated when the 05 Council refused
to sign off on an upgrade to Keter Class for
a clearly dangerous SCP that poses extreme
risk of containment breach?
Don’t blame them - it’s simply that Site-100
didn’t sanction the change.
Any time that Site-100 sanctions a new SCP,
it also undergoes another unique process:
It selects an SCP-001-K instance for the new
Keter, and creates a connection between them
- using access points known as “Thresholds.”
Think of it as simply opening a spatially-anomalous
door between two SCPs.
Much like A Good Boy, another SCP vying for
the 001 slot, Site-100 has an intuitive grasp
of the unseen connections between Keter-Class
anomalies, and each SCP-001-K instance is
a complementary Keter Class that will essentially
cancel out the threat of its other half.
Site-100 is a containment matchmaker, its
innate ability to use the anomalous to contain
the anomalous is second to none.
First, it took SCP-3984, an anomalous phenomenon
that seemed to prevent death from happening
to all lifeforms.
In order to mitigate the effects of 3984,
Site-100 opened a threshold between it and
SCP-2935, also known as “O, Death” - an
alternate universe hidden beyond a limestone
cavern where all life simultaneously ceased
to exist, even down to the bacterial level.
By opening the threshold and allowing these
two absolute opposites to mix, it seemed to
undermine the effects of both and create a
non-anomalous happy medium: Life, but mortal
life.
Next, SCP-5007.
This terrifying underwater anomaly manifests
as a series of tentacle-like protrusions that
snatch unfortunate creatures that get too
close, and assimilate them into its own mass.
Site-100 cleverly opened a threshold to SCP-169,
a massive underwater arthropod known as The
Leviathan.
SCP-169 was tangled up by the tentacles, but
it’s too big to be fully consumed or assimilated,
and the result is that 5007 is trapped in
a perpetually incapaciated state akin to choking,
keeping it contained and stopping it from
going after anyone else.
Let’s take a look at two even more hostile
and dangerous Keter-Class anomalies matched
up by Site-100.
First, we’ve got SCP-5501, an old camera
from the 1800s that comes with 18 photographs.
These photographs act as a kind of portal
to an incredibly frightening alternate reality
that creatures regularly crawl out of, attacking
and killing anyone within reach.
Site-100 found a perfect match for this nasty
customer: SCP-1983.
This is a small house that acts as a portal
to a race of tall monsters with needle-like
appendages that leave the house in search
of victims.
When they catch these victims, they take out
their hearts, and bring them back to the nest.
Site-100 opened a threshold into the SCP-1983
house and placed the 5501 photographs inside.
As a result, the hostile creatures from both
dimensions now regulate each other’s populations
by killing each other.
Another job well done for Site-100.
Another Keter-Class dealt with by Site-100
is SCP-PL-122.
This is a deadly plot of land in Poland, which
decays and corrodes all matter - organic or
inorganic - placed within its confines.
This would be bad enough, but as you’ll
often find with anomalous plots of deadly
land, its area of influence is growing.
Even knowing about it can cause it to become
more powerful.
But Site-100 found its perfect Keter-Class
counterpart: SCP-1262.
This is a massive mass of plant matter that
grows at a truly astonishing rate, expanding
by around seven kilometers an hour.
Much like absolute death and absolute life,
by putting 1262 into SCP-PL-122, a healthy
medium was found somewhere in between.
And finally, perhaps the strangest and most
creative match Site-100 has ever pulled off:
SCP-3852 and SCP-2547.
3852 is an anonymous corpse that manifests
in small towns, sowing fear and suspicion.
Eventually, a local person is believed to
be responsible for this murder, and is lynched
in a rage by the townspeople as a form of
vigilante justice.
The corpse then moves on to the next town.
2547, if you can believe it, is even weirder:
It’s a pack of dogs led by an intelligent
talking Coyote dressed as a priest.
Site-100 had the truly galaxy-brain idea to
open a threshold and connect the two.
As a result, whenever the corpse manifests
in the town, the dogs rampage in and take
over.
At that point, they set up a kind of ridiculous
kangaroo court, where a jury made up of people
from the town are forced to find 3852’s
scapegoat innocent.
If they don’t, the dogs will simply hold
the town’s water supply hostage until 3852’s
anomalous effects pass.
Such an obvious idea!
Now why didn’t the Foundation think of that?
Keter Duty may not be the most conventional,
easy, or attractive work, but like everything
the Foundation does, making sure Site-100
can keep doing its job is a necessary part
of keeping our world safe from anomalous threats.
Now if you’ll excuse us, we need to get
going.
Hmmm.
Do you know which is the right Root out of
here?
Say, kids, would you like to hear a story?
Cause we’ve got a really good one for you.
Seriously.
You're going to love it.
It's a classic rags to riches tale, about
one man's rise from humble beginnings to becoming
one of history's greatest and most visionary
toymakers.
Or maybe it isn't, maybe it's about a company
that literally came from nothing, whose origins
are still shrouded in mystery.
Maybe it's about a woman breaking the glass
ceiling to take over the toy company left
to her by her eccentric father.
Maybe it's about all of these things, but
the one thing we can tell you about the story
of Dr. Wondertainment is that every word of
it is true.
Or at least, as far as anything is true in
the weird, wonderful world of the SCP Foundation.
As long as you believe, we’ll all have a
wonderful time.
As long as you believe, nothing can hurt you...Not
in the fabulous world of Dr. Wondertainment!
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his relatively benign nature, has
been classed as Safe by the Foundation.
Rather than focusing on containing Wondertainment
himself, the SCP Foundation has centered its
efforts on containing the products that he
creates.
He is a Class-1 reality warper, capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects and
imbuing them with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical, and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are distributed
by as-yet unknown means.
Many of Wondertainment's toys are in the Foundation’s
possession, such as SCP-445, origami paper
that takes on properties of whatever it's
folded to look like, and SCP-3147, lollipops
that allow people to switch voices with each
other.
Dr. Wondertainment was born into a family
of humble means.
His mother was a seamstress and his father
was an accountant.
Unsatisfied with his mundane life, Wondertainment's
only joy growing up was in the stories that
his father would tell him about an ancestor
of his who was once a famous toymaker.
Inspired by these stories, Wondertainment
developed an interest in crafting toys, and
as an adult, set out to learn the secrets
he would need to create toys unlike anything
the world had ever seen.
He spent his life following rumors of magical
artifacts and enchanted trinkets, until his
search brought him to a mysterious factory.
If you've seen our previous videos on SCP-001
proposals, you can probably guess that this
factory was The Factory, the mysterious place
where new SCPs are supposedly created.
Wondertainment barely escaped the massacre
and the Foundation takeover of the Factory
with his life, but he was able to find a variety
of notes that he took with him.
These notes contained clues that led him to
the workshop of his famous toy maker ancestor,
and from there, he reclaimed his birthright.
That was the day that he truly became Dr.
Wondertainment.
It's a fun story, isn't it?
Very straightforward.
But perhaps it's a little underwhelming for
an SCP-001 proposal.
After all, SCP-001 is the collective designation
given to some of the most important anomalies
of all time - including many that could have
potentially been involved in the Foundation’s
very founding.
Let's start again.
Reginald Philbert Lionel Archibald Westinghouse
Wondertainment III is the name given to SCP-001,
who, due to his highly unpredictable nature,
has been classed as Euclid by the Foundation,
and he is to be detained as soon as his location
can be ascertained.
Until he can be captured, the SCP Foundation
has focused its efforts on containing the
products that he creates.
He is a Class-2 reality warper, capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects and
imbuing them with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical, and potentially
dangerous toys, games, candy, soft drinks
and other products aimed at children and young
teens.
These products are distributed by as-yet unknown
means.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as the often imitated
but never matched Little Misters collection,
which are a group of living collectibles with
unique anomalous properties.
Due to Wondertainment's reality-warping abilities,
it's impossible to pin down concrete information
about his history.
What we can tell you for sure is that he's
immortal, and ageless, and comes from a long
line of Wondertainments stretching all the
way back to the Cretaceous Period, where they
made all sorts of toys for the good little
dinosaur children.
It's also widely known that he is in fact
not a real person, but merely the manifestation
of the dreams of every child on earth, brought
forth solely by the power of imagination.
No confirmed sightings of Dr Wondertainment
have ever occurred, but witnesses have described
him as “dashing”, “very handsome for
his age”, and a “lovely chap, capable
of creating whimsy and wonder with the snap
of his fingers.”
He's a tall man, about the height of a piece
of string, and he's immediately recognizable
by his walking stick and W-shaped moustache.
It's also been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists, almost
as if his hands had been removed and reattached
at some point.
However, the truth of the matter is that-
Hm.
No, no, we're telling it all wrong again.
This doesn't do anything to capture the scope
of the Wondertainment story.
It needs to feel bigger, more comprehensive.
Let's try it again.
Dr Wondertainment is a trademark of the Wondertainment
Toy Company, the name given to SCP-001, a
corporation that, due to its consistent output
of anomalous items, is classed by the Foundation
as Keter.
Until this company can be permanently shut
down, the SCP Foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that it creates.
The collective power of the company's constituent
employees and the technology they make use
are equivalent to that of a Class-3 reality
warper.
The Wondertainment company produces and sells
a range of products, ranging from the seemingly
normal to the downright weird, all imbued
with anomalous properties.
The company has become infamous for their
constant output of bizarre, magical, and potentially
dangerous toys, games, candy, soft drinks
and other products aimed at children, teens,
and young at heart adults.
These products are made and distributed from
Wonder World - trademark - a location that
is as-yet unknown to the Foundation but offers
factory tours every hour from Tuesday to Friday.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as Wondertainment's
famous Dragon Snails – the real fire breathing
pet you can keep in your pocket!
Not much is known about the inner workings
of the Wondertainment company.
The SCP Foundation has no information currently
on the company's leadership structure, location,
history, or corporate policies.
Various former and current employees have
been interviewed regarding their experiences
working for Wondertainment, but they never
seem to be able to remember very much of use.
Those interviewed variously describe the Wondertainment
company as a regular office building, an immense
toy factory, an amusement park, but all agree
it's the best place they've ever worked!
In fact, you should apply for a job there!
We- I mean- they- have a few openings in their
legal department....or so I've heard.
Oh, silly me, it seems we've gotten off topic.
You're here to hear about the SCP-001 proposal.
Posting a job ad wasn't what I meant to do
when I hacked into- I mean, well… don’t
worry about that.
Forget I said a thing.
Now, let's try this again, but this time,
we'll add a twist.
Isabel Helga Anastasia Parvati Wondertainment
the Fifth is the name given to SCP-001, who
due to her ability to spread sunshine and
whimsy wherever she goes, has been classed
as Thaumiel by the Foundation, and due to
her immensely unpredictable nature, the SCP
foundation has resolved to just leave her
be.
Because she can't be captured, the SCP foundation
has focused its efforts on containing the
products that she creates.
She is a Class-4 reality warper, capable of
constructing wonderful, fun-tastic objects
and imbuing them with anomalous properties.
She's famous and widely beloved for using
this ability to create bizarre, magical and
not even a little bit dangerous toys, games,
candy, soft drinks and other products aimed
at everyone from ages 9 to 99.
These products are distributed by as-yet unknown
means.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as SCP-3551 - the
awesome inflatable alien invaders, and SCP-2514,
a lovely horse who can sing Happy Birthday!
How grand!
Wondertainment inherited the Wondertainment
name from her father, who either passed away
or never existed at all.
The circumstances of his death and perhaps
non-existence were very messy, involving a
mass murderer, the leader of a shadowy international
extra-governmental paramilitary organization,
at least one deity, and four bent paper clips.
She owns six corgis, and all of them are named
Jeremy.
In her free time, she likes to-
No no, this is still wrong.
Alright, enough is enough.
You want to know who Dr. Wondertainment really
is?
Well, you asked for it.
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his deity-level power, has been
classed as Apollyon by the Foundation.
There is no possible way to contain him.
He is a Class-5 reality warper, capable of
breaking down and reconstructing the very
laws of reality.
Did you really think that those little trinkets
were the full extent of my...
I mean his creations?
Did you truly think of him as such a small,
petty creature?
Dr. Wondertainment is no mere toysmith…
No, he is a god.
Want examples of his creations?
Just look around you!
Everything from the most innocent Safe-class
to the most harrowing Keter-class, it's all
thanks to him.
He's behind everything!
Marshall Carter and Dark, the Sarkists, The
Church of the Broken God, even the Scarlet
King himself!
All that time, all that effort, all it came
down to was one entity, one singular living
personification of chaos.
One day the SCP Foundation will finally give
up trying to find out how he distributes his
products, when they will finally see how small
and worthless their attempts to restore order
really are.
AND THEY WILL BE DRIVEN BEFORE HIS POWER,
THEY WILL CRUMBLE AND DECAY INTO NOTHINGNESS,
YOU WILL BOW BEFORE DR.
WONDERTAINMENT!
Had you going for a second there, didn't we?
You should've seen the looks on your faces.
But let's start again, one more time.
We're being serious this time.
Mask off, here's the true story of Dr. Wondertainment.
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his relatively benign nature, has
been classed as Neutralized by the Foundation.
Rather than focusing on containing Wondertainment
himself, the SCP foundation has focused its
efforts on containing the products that he
creates.
He is a reality warper whose limits have yet
to be documented, capable of constructing
otherwise normal objects and imbuing them
with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are distributed
by as-yet unknown means.
Due to his secretive nature, almost nothing
is known of Dr. Wondertainment's true origins,
and the waters have been muddied extensively
by the side effects of his reality-warping
ability.
In fact, it's entirely possible that Dr. Wondertainment
himself doesn't know who he is anymore.
It's possible that all the proposed origins
and descriptions of Dr. Wondertainment are
true in their own way, but it's equally possible
that none of them are.
All that's known for sure is that Dr. Wondertainment
- be they male or female, corporation or single
individual - is a constant thorn in the SCP
Foundation's side.
No matter what they really are, they’re
not going away soon, and only time will tell
who they’ll be tomorrow, or what further
horrors they and their company will create.
And that’s where our story will have to
come to an end.
At least, for now.
We hope you enjoyed it, and remember: Keep
believing.
Let’s get one thing clear.
As much as it is fun to go through the various
articles on the SCP Archive, we should take
a moment to acknowledge that it’s all fun
and games.
The SCP Foundation, all the entities and objects,
creatures and people, places and stories related
to them are just that: stories.
Fiction created by the authors of an online
wiki website.
It’s all designed to be a bit of harmless
entertainment.
But what if it isn’t harmless?
What if the characters within the world of
the SCP Archive somehow knew they had been
created by the SCP Wiki authors?
What would happen if fiction was aware that
it was, in fact, fictional?
Ask yourself, would you want to know if your
world, your life, everything you had ever
seen or known was all just a fantasy?
If the answer is no, then you need to stop
watching this video right now, but we’ll
warn you, just because you don’t know about
something, doesn’t necessarily stop it from
being true.
Still want to find out what’s going on?
Good, then you need to hear about SCP-001.
First things first, which of the various SCP-001s
are we talking about?
Anyone looking for the earliest SCP will quickly
discover that there are many different entities
and anomalies that share that number.
There are a few, in-universe reasons for this.
One is that all these anomalies were discovered
in the earliest days of the SCP Foundation,
before their current numbering system was
introduced.
Then there’s the other theories.
For example, some have speculated that the
existence of many different SCP-001s is an
intentional misdirection by the Foundation,
their way of keeping the nature of the true
first SCP a closely-guarded secret.
Regardless of what the reason is, the SCP-001
we’re looking at today is also known as
“The Database.”
Any and all information about The Database
is kept a secret from the entire SCP Foundation
apart from the Overseer Council.
And why is it such a secret?
Well, that’s because SCP-001 contains details
of the very nature of the Foundation itself,
including its creation.
But we don’t mean when and how the organization
was founded, or its history.
We mean how it was created, and by whom, in
our reality.
Confused?
Well, allow us to explain it.
At first, the file for SCP-001 describes a
group of humanoid entities that have an ability
to influence reality.
All sounds like pretty standard, bread and
butter stuff for the SCP Foundation, right?
WRONG.
These entities are, in actual fact, the authors
of the SCP Wiki themselves.
As in, the people in the real world.
The reality of the SCP Foundation is constantly
changed by these writers; written and rewritten
whenever someone edits an article on the SCP
Wiki.
That’s all fine and harmless for us, but
the Wiki authors’ impact on their world
is a cause of grave concern for the Foundation.
As we mentioned at the start, we all know
that the SCP Foundation and it’s vast catalogue
of user-generated articles on the creative
and the creepy are nothing more than a source
of fictional online entertainment.
It can be fun to study the lore and the nuances
of the different SCPs.
It can be enjoyable appreciating the creativity
and hard work that the authors put into writing
them.
In the case of fan fiction, independent stories,
original SCPs, or even animated videos dedicated
to explaining them, it can even inspire and
fuel our own written endeavors.
But, at the end of the day, when all is said
and done, we all know that the SCP Foundation
is purely fictional.
What we don’t realize is that the Foundation
knows it too.
Containing several pieces of information from
within their own archive, The Database contains
everything the Foundation knows about our
real world.
This includes everything about the real authors
of the SCP Wiki.
And you thought Deadpool was meta.
You see, because the SCP Wiki has articles
from numerous different creative writers,
chances are, the details of every new article
might not always line up with every previous
one.
For a long time, there has been much discussion
amongst devoted SCP fans regarding the “canon”
of the website.
Now, we don’t mean a big gun that launches
metal balls.
When we say canon, we mean all of the events
and stories that are considered to be an official
part of the on-going story of the SCP Foundation.
Still with us so far?
Because there are so many writers and articles
on the Wiki, the canon of the SCP Archive
is a bit inconsistent, to say the least.
And that’s fine for us, because we know
none of it is real.
It doesn’t have to all line up, just as
long as a good story is being told.
But these inconsistencies; all the little
cracks of discrepancy and disparity; are what
made the Foundation themselves realize that
they are truly living in a fiction.
In other words, SCP-001 is the SCP Foundation’s
window through what we would experience as
the fourth wall.
The fourth wall is the metaphorical barrier
that separates what we know to be real, from
what we know to be purely fiction.
In other words, it’s the line between the
audience and the fiction that they are watching,
the edge of the stage or the glass of the
television screen.
And the SCP Foundation is staring through
that fourth wall, looking out at you and me.
That’s right, it isn’t just the authors
that the Foundation are aware of, it’s all
of us.
According to their own researchers, the Foundation
has determined that we, the audience and the
writers, exist in something known as the Alpha
Layer.
What on Earth is an Alpha Layer?
Well, imagine our reality, the world and the
universe as we know it, is a slice of bread.
It’s a strange analogy, we know, but stick
with us.
Now, picture the fictional world of the SCP
Foundation as another slice of bread underneath
ours.
In-between the two can be whatever you like,
but the point isn’t that the world is a
sandwich.
The point is, that we exist on a layer of
reality above that of the SCP Wiki, and the
filling is just what keeps reality and fiction
separate.
So, as we mentioned, the Foundation is aware
of any writers and readers of the SCP Wiki,
and this does include you.
But the Wiki authors are the primary focus
of The Database.
After all, it’s the writers who are responsible
for creating the fictional world that the
SCP Foundation exists in.
Anything that forms a part of the narrative
of that world, every article, every tale,
every new SCP that gets published, even parts
of the Wiki that get taken down or rewritten
all have an impact on the Foundation’s universe.
When authors link their new SCPs to pre-existing
ones, or create connections to a Group of
Interest like the Church of the Broken God
or the Global Occult Coalition, their writing
ends up making even more of a substantial
development to the overall narrative.
And all of it ends up in The Database.
The readers of the SCP Wiki, on the other
hand, are a smaller part of SCP-001.
Mainly because they do not write or publish
the content found on the website itself.
Anything that is not specifically set in stone
by a Wiki author, can be interpreted in various
ways by a reader.
A reader’s interpretation is a powerful
concept, and should not be underestimated.
Interpretation is the difference between reading
Animal Farm as a story about a group of animals
rebelling against their human farmer, and
understanding it as a satirical and political
allegory for the events leading up to the
Russian Revolution.
So what does interpretation have to do with
SCP-001?
The point we are getting at is that any unwritten
detail or anything that isn’t explicitly
stated by a Wiki author, can be changed by
a reader’s own imagination.
This can be anything, from the appearance
or personality of an SCP or character, to
a detail about the world of the Foundation.
And in the same vein, if something in one
SCP article contradicts something written
in another, the reader is free to choose which
of them they accept as part of the universe’s
true canon.
Each reader of the SCP Wiki has their own
understanding of the material written there,
and inevitably comprehends their own version
of the events within.
And this is something that the SCP Foundation,
even in their world of fiction, is aware of
- or more specifically, the O5 Council is
aware of.
You see, the secretive overseers are the only
ones with any knowledge of SCP-001.
Only they can access The Database, only they
know the truth.
The fact that they exist in this fictional
capacity is something the Overseer Council
hopes to hide from the rest of the Foundation’s
personnel.
In an effort to keep the rest of their staff
from asking too many questions, the Council
has told them that there is currently no way
in existence that they could possibly contain
SCP-001.
But, to reassure personnel, the O5s have also
stated that this does not pose any risk, nor
would it lead to the total and utter destruction
of their observable, fictional universe.
Instead, the Council aims to focus on what
they can control, by containing any and all
information about SCP-001.
Nothing about The Database, or the truth that
it contains, is to ever leave O5 Command under
any circumstance whatsoever.
All of the information about SCP-001, or what
it contains, is kept in an encrypted, highly-classified
form, at an unknown location.
The key needed to decrypt this data is a pass
code split into three parts.
This key is then memorized by members of the
O5 Council, each memorizing a different portion
of the pass code.
It can only be accessed if every member of
the Council unanimously agrees that it is
absolutely necessary.
And even when they do decrypt the information
about SCP-001, it remains for the eyes of
O5 Command, and strictly their eyes only.
Any member of the SCP Foundation caught leaking
data about SCP-001 is to be contained by any
means necessary.
This also includes if a member of personnel
attempts to get this classified information
out via espionage, psychic leakage, or other
devious methods.
Foundation researchers are even banned from
conducting any of their own investigations
into the nature of SCP-001, or the data it
contains.
If a lower level staff member was to somehow
find out the truth, that the entire Foundation
is just a fiction, then that person would
be at the mercy of the most senior figure
on the O5 Council.
It would be up to that senior figure to decide
the staff member’s fate.
Anyone with high enough clearance or status
within the Foundation who found out about
SCP-001, would alternatively be given a Class
A amnestic.
These are memory altering drugs that the SCP
Foundation uses to keep information about
anomalies a secret.
Apparently, even from its own staff.
Still, having your mind wiped has got to be
better than being killed or contained, just
for realizing you’re a fictional character
on an online wiki.
The O5 Council have plans in mind for us,
and for the SCP Wiki writers responsible for
creating them.
The SCP Wiki entry on The Database closes
with a proposal; a way that the O5 Council
can reach out of their fiction, directly to
the wiki’s authors in the real world.
From there?
Their goal is simple: through memetic kill
agents, the SCP Foundation will put the Wiki
authors to sleep and then kill them.
Sounds pretty far-fetched, doesn’t it?
After all, when was the last time something
fictional killed someone in our real world?
Even more bizarre, what if this kill agent
already exists?
The O5 Council must have known for a while
that their world is fictional, so they’ve
had plenty of time to develop a kill agent,
some way of reaching us and the SCP Wiki authors
in the real world.
Worse still, what if this kill agent is already
out there somewhere, lurking on the SCP Archive,
just waiting for you to find it?
And if you read it, how would it kill you?
If you don’t want to know, then that’s
your choice to make.
But if curiosity is getting the better of
you, then remember this: Beware SCP-5999.
If you ask anyone, any person from any culture,
any part of the world, to describe what death
looks like, most people will immediately jump
to a depiction of the Grim Reaper.
And rightly so, the Reaper has long been the
personification of death and decay.
An omen of demise, the cloaked skeleton bearing
a sharp scythe, coming to collect souls and
carry them off to either Heaven or Hell.
For centuries, human beings have thought of
the Grim Reaper as death itself, but he’s
more of an embodiment of it, a symbol meant
to represent that all-too-familiar fear of
not knowing what lies beyond life on this
fragile mortal plane of existence.
Death itself, the real death, looks completely
different.
Welcome to the story of SCP-001.
Now, first things first, to anyone familiar
with the SCP Foundation, you will most likely
know that there are multiple SCP-001s.
You might even think you know which of them
is the real one.
But for those of you who are new here, allow
us to clarify for you this important context.
The designation of “SCP-001” doesn’t
refer to a single creature, object or entity,
but rather a collection of various anomalies
that are allegedly kept contained by the SCP
Foundation.
Now, there are multiple explanations as to
why these various files are all collected
under the shared designation of SCP-001.
One explanation could be that this is because
these anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the Foundation.
By this rationale, all the SCP-001s share
the same designation because they were first
encountered before the SCP Foundation established
the numbering system that it currently uses.
However, there also exists a theory that this
is nothing more than intentional misdirection.
If we choose to believe this explanation,
then it could mean that the many different
SCP-001s are a devious ploy by the Foundation
themselves.
In the interest of maintaining secrecy and
security, having many files sharing the name
SCP-001 could be the Foundation’s way of
keeping the nature of the true first SCP a
closely guarded secret.
It seems plausible that the multiple SCP-001
files could be an attempt by the Foundation
to conceal information.
After all, it wouldn’t be the first time
this secretive organization deceived someone.
So, what exactly is this particularly morbid
take on SCP-001?
Well first, you have to have a pretty high
level of security clearance within the SCP
Foundation if you want to even come close
to accessing this file.
In fact, any and all details about the anomaly
codenamed Dead Men is protected by Hellenstic,
an AIC used by the Foundation’s Overwatch
Command, also known as the O5 Council.
An AIC, for those who are not yet aware, is
an advanced form of artificial intelligence
that the Foundation develops and uses to run
parts of its archive of anomalies.
What does that mean for SCP-001?
Well, it’s pretty simple: the people in
charge of the Foundation want this file to
remain secure.
Or it could be because the O5 Council is hiding
something, something that the general staff
members aren’t meant to know about.
Getting past all the additional security surrounding
this particular file, we learn that SCP-001,
or this one at least, is...
An old man.
An 84 year old man, to be precise.
Wait, that’s it?
That’s what the big, closely guarded secret
is?
Just some old guy?
No, of course he’s not just “some old
guy”, the Foundation’s highest ranking
members wouldn’t go through such trouble
over one ordinary man.
This particular man has become one with death.
Not the Reaper, no… death itself.
The very concept of death has been merged
with this individual.
A lot more interesting than just a normal,
old man, right?
To be clear, this man is not an incarnation
or embodiment of death like the Grim Reaper.
Instead, he has become a vessel for the process
of making something that was once alive, not.
So, this old man, SCP-001, can control life
and death?
Not quite.
The old man’s body is more like a way that
death itself can be influenced.
It may help to picture it like this - Imagine
SCP-001 as a television remote control for
death.
Except instead of pressing buttons like you
would on a remote, you have to remove or alter
parts of the old man’s body.
And in doing so, you can manipulate the process
of death, albeit only to a limited extent.
You can’t, for example, permanently stop
death from existing or occurring, stopping
everyone around the world from dying.
That’s not quite how SCP-001 works.
Here, let’s give you an example.
SCP-001 had his tongue removed as well as
had sustained damage to his eardrums before
he was contained by the Foundation.
So, as a result of those alterations to his
body, there are fewer “Deals with Death”
events in the modern era.
You see what we mean now?
Changing SCP-001 changes how death functions,
but doesn’t necessarily stop it from happening.
So in essence, although there are parameters,
SCP-001 is the Foundation’s way of controlling
death itself.
How did they decide to go about doing this?
Well, once we tell you, you will understand
why the O5 Council wanted to keep information
about SCP-001 such a secret.
After performing a series of complex brain
surgeries and various other procedures on
the old man, the Overwatch Command intentionally
engineered him to be unable to perceive certain
people.
Who were those people?
You guessed it, the O5 Council themselves.
Making SCP-001 unable to recognize the faces
of any O5 Council members, means that death
is unable to see or perceive the council members
either.
All those pieces fit together to form a particularly
unsettling jigsaw puzzle: by tampering with
SCP-001, the O5 Council have made themselves
effectively immortal.
They cannot die, nor will they age or decay
like normal, mortal human beings.
Death still occurs of course, other beings
can die, but the council members are exempt
from that fundamental law of nature.
The Foundation believes that SCP-001 was initially
created by an occult group known as The Eternal
Circle.
Thanks to records recovered from the Circle’s
London headquarters, the SCP Foundation now
knows that they were the ones responsible
for merging the old man with the concept of
death.
When their personnel first recovered SCP-001,
the old man was frail, in a poor physical
condition and barely responded to any external
stimuli.
Research staff believed he must have suffered
severe trauma at the hands of the Eternal
Circle, evidenced by the circular symbols
that had been carved into his back, oh, and
also the fact that his body parts had all
been modified.
Contained within the file for this SCP-001
is a letter directly from the O5 Council themselves,
explaining their reasons for using the old
man to become immortal.
They justify their actions by claiming that
they have a wealth of experience in containing
anomalies and keeping the SCP Foundation running.
This is, to them, a perfectly valid reason
to make themselves exempt from death, rather
than aging, retiring and dying, to later be
replaced by new members on the Overwatch Council.
They claim that their immortality is not for
their own self benefit of course, but for
the good of the Foundation as an organization,
and by extension, the world as a whole.
The council also promised that the same death
exempt status would later be extended to other
vital members of personnel.
However, according to the Hellenstic AIC guarding
the file “No personnel have been considered
for death-exempt status in the future.”
In other words, the O5 Council were lying,
and intended to keep their Get out of Death
Free card to themselves.
It wasn’t long before the Foundation’s
very own Ethics Committee learned about what
the Council was up to, and naturally, they
had some concerns.
According to a report issued by committee
chairman Odongo Tejani, the way the O5 Council
were using SCP-001 to prolong their own lives
was immoral and inhumane, even by their own
strange standards.
By using this poor, frail old man for their
own gain, the Council had warped the natural
way death should work, and threatened to anomalously
unbalance the very laws of nature.
The Ethics Committee had no other choice but
to dispatch its own Mobile Task Force, known
as Omega 1, or the “Law’s Left Hand”,
to rectify the situation.
Their mission?
To detain all members of the O5 Council at
their next meeting, removing them from office
and replacing them with high ranking candidates
from within the Foundation’s lower ranks.
Finally, they also planned to neutralize SCP-001,
cleaning house and removing the temptation
for future council members to make themselves
immortal.
In short, this was a coup.
The O5 Council was going to be overthrown
by their own ethics committee.
Of course, the council were more than prepared
for this, and had their very own Mobile Task
Force on hand to defend them against the plot.
Alpha 1, also known under the codename “Red
Right Hand” - the legendary lackeys of the
O5 Council - clashed with the Law’s Left
Hand.
It is believed that the shadowy Administrator
of the SCP Foundation also had his own personal
task force, possibly Rēsh 1, also called
the “Seat of Consciousness”, enter the
fray.
In other words, we were looking at an absolutely
insane three-way Foundation civil war bloodbath.
How exciting!
Security footage showed these three groups
engaged in a fire fight within Site 01, using
Foundation training and tactics against each
other in what was probably the most epic battle
of all of their lives.
It was absolute chaos - the air thick with
screams and gunsmoke.
Cameras also picked up a group of men and
women, lying all around Site 01, many wounded
but still alive.
Impressive, given how many of them had taken
gunshots right to their heads.
That’s right, these were presumed to be
the members of the O5 Council, still unable
to die despite being shot.
It is unclear which of the MTFs was responsible
for this, the Ethics Committee had only intended
Law’s Left Hand to secure the council members.
It could well be that they were caught in
the crossfire that occurred as the Law’s
Left Hand and Red Right Hand teams fought.
Unless, of course, the Administrators task
force were the ones who had stepped in and
shot the O5 Council.
Through all the chaos that had unfurled, SCP-001
was still in his cell.
And he wasn’t alone.
An unknown figure had somehow gained access,
and he conversed with SCP-001.
The man went on to tell SCP-001 that the Foundation
was wrong to tamper with the nature of death,
and recounted a story.
He said that he had once filed paperwork regarding
anomalies for an unknown organization, but
couldn’t live with the horror of what his
job entailed.
So, the man sold these files to a group of
thirteen individuals: the O5 Council.
They then went on to form a full organization,
the SCP Foundation as we know it.
The man then stated he was disgusted with
how the Foundation had used SCP-001, how the
council members had engineered the frail,
old man to make themselves immortal.
He had hoped they would be a force for good,
keeping any necessary evil to a minimum.
The unknown figure told SCP-001 that the conflict
between the council and the Ethics Committee
had happened many times before, with many
other versions of the old man.
Earlier SCP-001s, previously merged with the
concept of death.
He then helped SCP-001 identify the members
of the council, ending their immortality,
promising the weak, tired old man that he’d
finally be able to rest.
The unknown mystery man claimed that he would
always be in power, the O5 Council would always
bring him back.
After all, he was their figurehead, their
leader, the SCP Foundation Administrator himself.
In the end, the Administrator himself chose
to let himself perish too, perhaps in shame
of what his organization had become.
Or did he?
Because someone seems to have been accessing
the Hellenstic AIC and the SCP-001 file using
his login since this incident.
Maybe the hand of death doesn’t reach quite
as far as we were led to believe.
And that’s where the tale of SCP-001 ends;
a story of the Foundation’s greed in their
pursuit of eternal life.
We mustn’t forget that death isn’t something
to be afraid of, after all, it gives our lives
meaning knowing that they’ll one day end.
But when you look at the kind of monsters
we can become in the pursuit of eternal life,
well…
In the words of another wise old man, “Sometimes,
dead is better.”
Does the Black Moon Howl?
No. Not yet.
See the boy. He was born in a time before
names; there weren’t enough humans around
to need them back then. He was one of a handful
occupying a coastal village, using a tongue
long since dead. They eked out a simple life
- hunting, gathering, fishing. The only thing
on most of their minds was surviving to see
the next sunrise. Yes, a simple life, free
of complications.
Until The Hermit appeared.
The Boy would remember this man for an eternity.
Haggard and thin; skin weathered by time and
pain. A man that, emaciated, walking with
a long, gnarled cane that honestly looked
healthier than he did, shouldn’t be alive.
Even the Boy, who had scarcely seen beyond
the bounds of his village, knew that the Hermit
was unnatural. An aberration. An anomaly.
He walked into the center of the village,
sat down on a large stone, and waited. Nobody
dared ask his business, nor what the Hermit
waited for.
Then, a few days later, the Black Moon howled.
The Boy saw the village’s youngest hunter
freeze one evening while out on a walk. Not
simply stand still, but freeze. Then, for
an instant, he became solid black. A coal
statue. And as soon as he’d changed, he
was gone. Obliterated. Not a trace of him
remained.
Such is the power of the Black Moon. It can
make any conscious being disappear in an instant.
Turned black, then wiped from our plane of
existence, never to be seen again. Its choice
of victim seemed, at each instance, to be
utterly random, but it would come for all
who lived eventually. This is known to some
as the howling of the Black Moon.
Later that same night, the Boy found himself
talking to the Hermit, who asked with small,
frantic eyes what he had seen. When the Boy
told him, he let out a deep, rattling sigh.
The Boy, curious, asked him if he knew about
the nightmare he’d just witnessed. The Hermit
looked up. He’d been the first one, in the
Hermit’s millennia of pursuit, that had
ever asked. In that moment, he knew he had
found his successor in the hunt for the Death
of Ages.
The Hermit told the Boy it went by many names.
The Great Finale, the Pale King, but most
common of all was the Black Moon. The entity
existed beyond the veil of our reality, a
creature of pure energy, though nobody could
really be sure of its true nature. The Hermit
had been tracking it, learning about it, and
trying to destroy it for thousands of years.
And yet, it only took him four pathetic minutes
to tell the Boy everything he knew.
The Boy, knowing still that something about
the Hermit was unnatural, asked how he came
to be in this position. The Hermit told the
boy he was the Counterbalance, a kind of chosen
one, destined to face and perhaps even defeat
the Black Moon someday. The Counterbalance
receives a number of truly extraordinary gifts
for inheriting the responsibility: Eternal
life, eternal youth, near physical immortality.
But they will be haunted by their purpose,
doomed to watch everyone they love die around
them, as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite, the Black Moon itself.
The Hermit, in his own eyes, had failed at
his duty. He had grown weary, and now, he
needed to pass the duty of Counterbalance
onto another. That other would be the Boy.
He felt a sudden and profound change, along
with the knowledge that nothing would ever
be the same again. He was no longer just the
Boy. Now, he was the Counterbalance.
He watched the Hermit give him a slight nod
out of respect, and then crumble into dust
before his eyes. The Boy, the Counterbalance,
looked up at the sky and saw the stars twinkling.
So bright, so beautiful. Little did he know,
his battle with the Black Moon would outlast
every single one of them.
Does the Black Moon howl? Not without blood.
The Boy grew into a man, as his village aged
and then died around him. Decades passed,
then centuries, then millennia. Tens of thousands
of years, watching humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit of
that one elusive foe.
As science and diagnostic technology gained
ground, absorbing and then evolving beyond
all the old superstitions, the Counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the Black
Moon - though even then, it still remained
essentially a stranger. The entity was entropic,
a being of pure randomness and chaos without
consistent form. It didn’t exist in our
universe, but it could exercise its influence
here with so-called “Obliteration Events”
- much like the horrible fate that befell
the young hunter from the village.
But that was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg.
The Counterbalance tracked and noted obliteration
events. They were exceedingly rare, at first.
Something that occurred once every thousand
years or so, like a terrible curse. But he
couldn’t help but notice a concerning trend
emerging. It started happening once a century...then
once a decade. He could feel the terrible
future stretching out in front of him. How,
over their shared eternity, the Black Moon
would gain more and more ground.
Would there come a day where it took someone
once a year? One a month? A week, a day, an
hour, a minute, a second? It’d spell the
end of all conscious life. A total victory
for the Black Moon, the End of the Universe,
the Death of Ages. A complete existential
obliteration.
He was swept up in a sobering realization:
He couldn’t win this fight alone.
However, while his hunt for the Black Moon
had been largely fruitless, the Counterbalance
had discovered many other things along the
way, Strange creatures, objects with extraordinary
powers, and events that couldn’t be explained
with rational science. Perhaps something among
these oddities, these anomalies, would hold
the key to defeating his timeless enemy. And
it hadn’t just been these objects, entities,
and events, he’d also discovered some truly
exceptional people on his travels. Minds and
skills that rivaled even his own, despite
his age.
Perhaps they would be the ones to help him
win.
With the thirteen most brilliant and trusted
people the Counterbalance ever met, he decided
to form a Council. And from this Council,
they forged and directed an organization dedicated
to understanding and counteracting the strange
in all its forms, with the secret hope that
their search into darkness would yield the
answer to the Black Moon’s downfall.
He called it the SCP Foundation. They would
Secure the anomalous, Contain it, and Protect
all of humanity from its influence. The Counterbalance
also took on a new title, befitting of his
new role: The Administrator. And even the
Black Moon itself was given a moniker, in
hopes of robbing it of some of its frightening
power.
SCP-001.
Does the Black Moon howl? Only at the blind.
The year was now 1987. The SCP Foundation
had been operating for over a century, and
thanks to their secret possession of anomalous
wisdom and technology, their own advancement
was thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity. While there still wasn’t a silver
bullet solution to the Black Moon, and its
deadly howls were becoming all the more frequent
as the decades went on, the Foundation did
have some irons in the fire to combat it.
Their ability to gather intel on both the
entity itself and its obliteration events
had improved considerably, thanks to their
new global information network. Their top
minds were also working on a highly classified
device known as the Singular Conceptual Bunker,
which may one day come in handy for combating
the extra-dimensional entity directly. But
the most valuable piece of information they
ever gathered about the Black Moon was this:
It couldn’t howl when it was being watched.
The very act of engaged observation defanged
it.
The problem is, how can you observe something
that doesn’t technically exist inside your
own reality? In order to pull this off, the
Foundation would need to get extremely creative.
Thankfully, creative solutions to strange
problems are the Foundation’s specialty.
Flash forward to 1993. Enter Dr. Moto, a brilliant
young scientist and conceptual engineer working
for the SCP Foundation. With The Administrator’s
consultation, he started the KEY Project,
an arm of the wider Project Oromasdes - the
umbrella initiative for using modified anomalous
objects in the battle against the Black Moon.
The goal of the KEY Project was relatively
simple: If people couldn’t observe the Black
Moon directly, then the Foundation could make
proxies of the Black Moon that could be observed,
almost like a kind of voodoo doll. These new
anomalies would only need to satisfy three
criteria: The inability to operate when being
observed, a hostility to conscious life, and
the ability to end conscious life of their
own volition when not being observed. Through
conceptual engineering, a link theoretically
could be forged between these objects and
the Black Moon, allowing observation of them
to stop the obliteration events.
However, despite being a good idea in theory,
Dr. Moto’s efforts were marred with errors
and tragedies. One object wasn’t deadly
enough, simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren’t looking.
Another one killed purely through collateral
damage - a giant sculpture of a human head
that immediately attempted escape by barging
through Site-01 - the center for Anti-Black
Moon operations - and killing nineteen people
in the process. Another one of Moto’s objects,
a huge black sphere, simply immediately exploded,
killing twelve people.
And in the most horrific misstep of all, one
of Moto’s objects caused a mass death event
in a nearby hotel, where 142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object - a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites - was
left unobserved for 0.2 seconds. Almost all
of Moto’s objects were terminated in the
aftermath, either being too useless or too
dangerous to keep around. The young scientist
felt a deep shame, but forged on.
He made one truly brilliant creation that
satisfied all the criteria: A sculpture, incapable
of moving while being watched, but would snap
the neck of the nearest conscious entity if
left unobserved for even a fraction of a second.
Its relatively minimal killing left it easy
to contain without causing mass deaths, and
despite all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the KEY Project, Dr. Moto
believed that the lives saved in the long
run by stopping the Black Moon’s howls would
justify the sacrifice.
The problem is...the KEY Project didn’t
stop anything.
Not long after this, there was the first recorded
double obliteration event in Rome, where a
young tourist couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously. All the deaths in the KEY
Project had been for nothing. The Black Moon
was only getting more powerful.
The shame and the guilt was too much for Dr.
Moto. He left a note in his office, reading,
“We've been looking at nothing. I'm sorry,
Administrator. I've failed you, sir.”
Moto’s corpse was later found in the sculpture’s
temporary containment chamber, his neck snapped.
The KEY Project was, in summary, shut down
and its one surviving creation transported
to Site-19 in late 1993, where it was designated
as SCP-173. Another painful failure for the
Administrator. Back to the drawing board once
more.
Does the Black Moon howl? Not while stars
shine.
millennia stretched on. Almost everyone died,
except The Administrator, thanks to his gift
- or perhaps curse - as the Counterbalance
to the Black Moon. Science marched on, the
SCP Foundation marched on, but all this progress,
all this power, was nothing against the incomprehensible
influence of SCP-001. The Black Moon was howling
more frequently than ever, all the way up
to the year 3156, when the Foundation launched
the SEEK Project under the support of Project
Oromasdes.
As more and more people were wiped out in
frequent obliteration events, the Administrator
became painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the Black Moon problem wouldn’t be found
on earth. Using state of the art technology,
with a little help from the anomalous, the
SCP Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search the
stars for the key to the Black Moon’s destruction.
It was an awe-inspiring creation, a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence, with a
universal translator, cryogenic units, and
hundreds of autonomous drones to perform more
targeted searches.
SEEK was waved off into the unforgiving depths
of space. The Administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile answers.
The first of the three notable planets SEEK
arrived on was one theoretically capable of
supporting human life, except for its brutal
and constant blizzards and snowstorms. When
SEEK’s drones were deployed, they did discover
signs of civilization, based around sentient
spherical creatures, but no signs of actual
life remained. Records and statues found across
the planet seemed to indicate that the Black
Moon was responsible for the destruction of
the planet’s civilization, causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining survivors
went mad from the fear and stress, leading
to mass death in the ensuing chaos.
The next planet was discovered centuries later,
in the year 3499. While this planet could
also theoretically support human life, it
suffered from frequent volcanic eruptions
that rendered much of its surface a flaming
mess. However, there were still the dormant
ruins of a once advanced civilization of conscious
beings. Much like the prior planet, they’d
been driven extinct by Black Moon obliteration
events a century before the SEEK even arrived.
Unlike the last planet, however, it seems
that they accepted their fate, and went gently
into the night. The planet was now overrun
by billions of armored, bat-like creatures
that operated on pure instinct, and thus,
were not considered conscious enough to be
obliterated.
The final planet was reached in 3764, and
was the most fruitful of the three discoveries.
This planet was hyper-advanced, fully urbanized
and covered in sprawling megacities, with
records and technology over a thousand years
ahead of Earth. Before the Black Moon killed
almost all of them, they were a species of
humanoid telepathic fungi, and had developed
an awareness of the Black Moon’s existence
that was on par with that of humanity’s.
They even had their own equivalent of the
SCP Foundation actively working on countermeasures.
And most amazingly of all, SEEK found one
surviving member of the species on the planet,
cryogenically frozen. The craft was immediately
instructed to collect the survivor and return
home for interrogation. The Administrator
was preparing for what could have been the
most important conversation since he met the
Hermit, all those thousands of years ago.
Does the Black Moon howl? Only when waning.
When the surviving creature, codenamed SAGE,
was returned to Earth, The Administrator was
eager to finally speak with it. Like the rest
of its now-extinct species, SAGE spoke through
powerful telepathic mindwaves, which only
The Administrator - thanks to his Counterbalance
abilities - was able to receive at close range
without being harmed.
Incidentally, it wasn’t long until the very
fact of the Administrator’s nature as a
Counterbalance came up in the mental conversation.
SAGE could tell, just by being in his presence.
They discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating: That SAGE’s
survival had been pure luck, for starters.
The Black Moon is still very much capable
of obliterating conscious beings in an unconscious
state. The Administrator also learned that
he was merely the latest in an extremely long
line of Counterbalances across time, space,
and species, though everyone but him had waived
the duty, passed it on.
SAGE had one question to ask the Administrator
in turn, “What is SCB?” The Singular Conceptual
Bunker, being worked on and perfected for
thousands of years by now, by the Foundation’s
top scientists and conceptual engineers.
The Administrator replied, “Victory. But
it will take a very, very long time.” Specifically,
so long that he would see the stars go out
around him, one by one. Shocked, SAGE asked
him what good victory would do him then. Rather
than say it aloud, he replied with a thought.
SAGE paused, and said, “I see. How blasphemous
of you. Hopefully it works.”
After this, the Administrator proceeded to
the Singular Conceptual Bunker and entered
it, leaving instructions for the Foundation
to be run by a newly formed O5 Council in
his indefinite absence. Thousands of years
later, in the year 5011, SAGE spoke one more
time, repeating the words, “Hopefully, hopefully”
before turning solid black, and disappearing.
The Black Moon had claimed one more victim,
but billions more had gone in the interim.
The Administrator had no more answers to give.
At least, no more answers that anyone but
him would understand. He was inside the Singular
Conceptual Bunker now, loaded into a device
known as TOME - an experimental memorial module,
meant to pick up and record all the last messages
of every dying civilization across the universe,
when the time finally came. All he could do
was wait. And wait was exactly what we did.
Does the Black Moon howl?
Yes. Yes it does.
Years pass. Too many to count. It’s a time
after names now, and TOME sits in the very
center, drinking in the end of the universe.
The last of all the human colonies across
the universe were obliterated by the Black
Moon back in the year 7329, so, so, so long
ago, but some of the final messages of fear,
panic, and distress still echoed around the
Administrator’s mind.
"Hello, is there anyone here? We — we require
assistance! There's … it's … it's taking
people every day! We need help! There's barely
anyone left! We need help! Hello? Hello?!"
"Cabal 09:43! We have abandoned the false
flesh! We have abandoned the false flesh!
The shepherds crook broken 'neath my knee!
Cabal 09:43! Cabal 09:43! Forgive us! Forgive
us!"
"We're going to leave this on. It's so dark
outside now. It's blotting out the sun. It's
… I have to go now."
"RESPOND•FIRST•CONVENIENCE EMERGENCY•SITUATION•DEVELOPING
REQUIRE•ADDITIONAL•RESOURCES."
"My fault. Your fault. Our fault. My fault.
Your fault. Our fault. My fault. Your fault.
Our fault. Rip out my brain now. Rip out my
brain now!"
And a small child, the last on Earth, simply
asking, “Hello?” into an indifferent microphone.
But the Administrator had to wait, as the
Singular Conceptual Bunker became the Solitary
Conceptual Bunker. He was the last conscious
being in the universe, and still, he needed
to wait, as the stars went dark outside. Only
when there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the Counterbalance’s
long game to pay off.
There was nothing left of our universe. The
only thing here was the SCB, and the Black
Moon itself. With everything else gone, the
Black Moon only had one conscious being left
to obliterate. It opened the door to the Solitary
Conceptual Bunker, and stepped inside.
This...this doesn’t make sense. How can
the Black Moon, an entity beyond our dimension,
beyond physical form, take a step? Good question.
The same question, incidentally, that was
going through the Black Moon’s mind as it
entered the bunker. It didn’t look at all
how the entity expected: It was like a bar,
a counter with rows of bottles behind it,
a jukebox playing in the corner. A man stood
behind the bar, cleaning glasses.
The Counterbalance. The Administrator.
He said, "Well, there you are! Certainly took
your time. Can I pour you a little something?"
This only served to increase the Black Moon’s
confusion. It had form here, dark smoke compressed
into a vaguely humanoid shape. It could speak?
It could think? None of this made any sense.
The being that’d just wiped out all conscious
life and seen the very death of the universe
was truly and utterly confused.
The Administrator just seemed to be enjoying
himself, preparing for a confrontation hundreds
of billions of years in the making. The Singular
Conceptual Bunker - or perhaps, the Singular
Containment Bunker - was a truly ingenious
creation. A place of pure ideas, where everything
inside was on the same level. Here, there
were no immortals. No Gods. Just ideas, on
the same level playing field. And it was time
for the Black Moon’s idea to come to an
end.
It was a trap, and the entire universe was
the bait.
Without warning, the Administrator pulled
up a shotgun from underneath the table, and
unleashed both barrels into the Black Moon’s
chest.
The creature took the hit and fought back,
dragging the Administrator to the ground,
beating him, strangling him. He could feel
the light fading under the monster’s relentless
assault, until he managed to get his desperate
hands on a glass ashtray. He beat the monster
over the head with it until its grip loosened,
and he was able to slide out.
There, the killer of the universe was on the
ground before him. He grabbed the monster,
held it in place, and beat it to death. He
was gravely injured by the battle, but The
Black Moon was no more. Here, in the Singular
Conceptual Bunker, he had won.
The Administrator, no longer the counterbalance
in the absence of the Black Moon, hobbled
over to the jukebox, producing a single, beautiful
coin from his pocket. He pushed the coin into
the slot, wheezed a pained breath, and said:
“The thing is … this place is only information.
T-There's nothing else out there. Not even
matter. The universe closed its doors a long
time ago. But this place can go from information
back to matter with just the press of a button.
L-Let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing…”
For a second, it looks as though he might
fall, but he doesn’t. Instead, he slams
the button on the jukebox and, with a relieved
laugh, says, “Let there be light.”
And there was light.
Hour one.
There is only one news story, on every website,
newspaper, and TV screen.
The flowers are blooming everywhere, all across
the globe.
Every country, every landmass.
The bitter cold of the Antarctic gives way
to a glowing rainbow of petals.
The Sahara Desert and Death Valley become
beacons of thriving technicolor plantlife.
The highest mountains, the lowest valleys,
the darkest caves.
The flowers even burst free from the concrete
of cities, as if reminding us that really,
it was never our world, we were only borrowing
it.
And today, our lease is up.
This is SCP-001.
Object Class: Unnecessary.
It was foretold by tales from other dimensions,
a distant future coming down the tracks towards
us.
And today, the train has reached the station.
Nobody’s reporting on how the economy or
the stock market is doing today.
No point.
Celebrity scandals have faded away into nothingness.
Greedy businessmen, lying politicians, brutal
tyrants.
None of them are making the headlines today.
The very last headlines.
The World’s Gone Beautiful.
And what a shame it takes the end of it all
to make us realize what really matters to
us.
That’s right: You’re looking at the end
of the world.
But it’s okay.
Don’t panic.
Take a deep breath, in and out.
It was bound to happen eventually, so no point
worrying now.
Even the Foundation knows that this just isn’t
something they can stop.
So instead of asking things like, “How can
we prevent this?” or “Do we have any final
tricks up our sleeve?”
let’s ask a different question entirely:
“What would you do if you knew that you
only had 24 hours until all life on earth
ends?”
Think hard.
After all, even if you never live to see the
flowers bloom, a final day will still come
for you, just as it does for us all.
Hour six.
A D-Class sits alone in his cell when he sees
the flowers growing out of the ground.
Normally, he’d assume this meant he was
in some kind of Foundation experiment.
But not today.
Everyone on earth has an innate sense that
the time is now.
A kind of gallows calm spreads out over everyone
and everything.
It’s over, and that’s okay.
We all knew it was going to happen eventually,
right?
He sighs and gives a slight smile.
Those flowers sure are beautiful.
That’s when he hears footsteps outside his
cell, approaching.
A key slides into his cell door, and it opens.
There stands Dr. Gears, holding a bottle of
wine and two glasses.
Anyone who knows him might think he’s been
replaced by some kind of shapeshifting anomaly
or had his mind taken over by a powerful cognitohazard.
But no.
It’s him.
The famously cold Dr. Charles Ogden Gears.
Dr. Gears says, “Come on.
It’s a lovely day out there.
It’d be a terrible waste to spend the whole
thing cooped up in here.”
It’d feel like a trick, on any day but this.
The D-Class nods and follows the doctor out.
The normally oh-so-stoic Foundation senior
researcher pours himself and the D-Class each
a glass of wine, and asks, “What’s your
name, by the way?
I don’t think I ever checked.”
The D-Class replies that his name is Harold.
The two smile and chat as they exit the now
empty D-Class containment wing.
Everyone else is outside already.
Researchers, guards, administrative staff,
and D-Classes, all rubbing elbows, enjoying
the beautiful sun on their last day together.
Elsewhere on the site, a flock of SCP-514
is released, just as identical flocks are
being released from every containment site
all over the world.
They’ve prepared it all for this very day.
SCP-514 is a special breed of homing pigeons
created by the Manna Charitable Foundation,
which have the power to suppress aggression
for those within their field of anomalous
influence.
And now, millions of them are flying all over
the world.
After all, there’s no point fighting on
a day like this.
There is no future left to secure.
People always told them there would forever
be hope until the flowers bloomed.
No situation was ever truly over until the
world went beautiful.
But in the absence of hope, there was something
even more inviting: Total, absolute calm.
The Site-19 personnel sit together and watch
the flowers bloom.
Hour Twelve.
All militaries call a global ceasefire.
Soldiers from opposing sides hug and shake
hands in flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood.
Borders fade; bitter rivalries turn to dust.
Korea unifies.
All is quiet in the Middle East.
Gangsters and drug cartels drop their weapons
and return home to their families and friends
as flocks of SCP-514 fly above.
What good is all the blood money in the world
on a day like this?
Wardens walk cell to cell through all the
world’s prisons, granting people their freedom
again, sometimes after lifetimes of not having
it.
They taste the air again.
Feel the sun on their face.
They close their eyes, drink it in, and walk
among the flowers.
Free men.
Locations of Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd.
close their doors and shutter their windows
worldwide.
For the first time in as long as any of them
can remember, they turn their signs to “Closed.”
They’ve earned a day off.
Everyone has.
The Chaos Insurgency rolls up their plans
and burns them.
They drop their weapons and throw away their
tactical gear.
As they do so, they can’t help but question
themselves: What was it all for, in the end?
What was any of it for?
All the fighting and bloodshed and death?
We did it day after day, only to do it again
the next day.
What silly reasons we killed and died for.
What silly reasons indeed.
The Global Occult Coalition dismisses its
staff, thanking them for their service and
telling them to go spend their last hours
with the ones they love.
Like the Foundation, they accept that this
is the one true, final end.
No ritual to stop, no monster to fight, no
evil extra-dimensional entity to thwart.
Just go outside and smell the flowers, while
you still can.
The Serpent’s Hand are similar.
They decide, after decades fighting a losing
battle, they’ll spend their last day in
the Wanderer’s Library, reading some of
their favorite volumes.
All these wonderful stories, now left for
other earths to read.
Their own stories would be counted among them
in the end, and they take great comfort in
that.
In a sense, everyone will live forever in
the pages of the books in the Wanderer’s
Library.
Herman Fuller’s Circus of the Disquieting
releases all of its freaks and clowns from
their twisted grasp, to go and live out whatever
small dreams and tiny pleasures they could
find over their last hours.
They have no Foundation to fear anymore.
Nobody minds their strange appearances and
odd behaviors.
Why would anyone waste such a beautiful day
judging others?
On the last day on earth, there’s nothing
left to prove.
Sarkicists drop their ancient, flesh-bound
tomes, and acolytes of the Broken God put
down their gilded blades.
On the slopes of Siberia, the jungles of Peru,
and the most isolated beaches of Mexico, twisted
flesh finally touch living metal in the spirit
of husbandry.
Their eternal war is at its end.
In the face of the blooming world, they didn’t
seem so different after all.
The agents of the Dr. Wondertainment corporation,
predictably, choose to spend their last hours
sitting around and playing with toys together.
Time well spent, if you ask us.
In a highly secretive location, perhaps the
most heavily secured place in the entire world,
the thirteen members of the legendary O5 Council
decide to just sit and talk.
As anyone who knows anything about this secretive
cabal can tell you, the O5 Council has spent
a considerable portion of their very, very
long lives trying to figure out ways to dodge
and cheat death.
But now, facing a death they can’t dodge,
the same calm washing over the rest of the
world has finally reached them too.
All they can really think this time is, “Well
played, Reaper, well played” as they chat
about the kind of inane, casual things they
haven’t had the time to discuss in years.
O5-3 suggests inviting the Ethics Committee
over to join.
Nobody disagrees.
Hour sixteen.
It isn’t just the D-Classes.
All sapient and non-aggressive SCPs have been
released from containment, free to spend the
last of their time as they wish.
Tens of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all over
the globe.
It’d be the greatest victory that the Serpent’s
Hand could ever ask for if they weren’t
all too busy reading to notice.
SCP-105, Iris Thompson, finally returns to
her parents.
The Foundation had fed them the lie that their
daughter had died many years before, but as
Iris had a tendency to do, she was ready to
work a miracle.
Her parents embrace her with open arms.
They’ll spend their last hours together
catching up on what’s happened since they
parted ways, and making up for lost time.
They couldn’t be happier.
SCP-1867, Lord Blackwood the fantastical sea
snail, is delivered into a warm rockpool near
the site where he was being contained.
There, he might finally have one more grand
adventure before all is said and done.
Though afterward, he may not have the time
to tell anyone about it.
A terrible shame, really, because nobody spins
a yarn like Lord Blackwood.
The non-aggressive little misters run free.
Mr. Fish eagerly returns to his native Boston,
Massachusetts, where he enjoys one more lobster
sandwich before the end of the world.
Mr. Headless decides to go hat shopping because
he wants to look good for the apocalypse.
Mr. Lost finally settles down for the afternoon,
deciding that, just this once, he’s earned
himself a rest.
SCP-2800, Cactusman, returns to Edinburgh,
to spend his last day picking up litter and
helping old ladies cross the street.
SCP-3663, the Tunnel Monster, walks the streets
of his hometown, searching for an old friend,
hoping to reunite before it all ends.
SCP-073, Cain, decides to take a walk outside
for the first time in thousands of years.
He can’t help but smile, as the bright,
colorful life beneath his feet is growing
faster than his presence can kill it.
What a truly beautiful day.
Knowing that there’s no longer time for
cults to form and bother him, SCP-2662, Cthulhu,
decides to take a break from his intense Minecraft
session and go take a walk outside.
It feels so good to have the sun on his tentacles
once more and to feel lush, green grass under
his suction cups.
He shakes his head, thinking once again about
the irritating cults that had been pestering
him for decades.
What kind of idiot would want him to destroy
a world like this?
SCP-343, also known as God, sighs and looks
over all his creation for what he knows to
be the last time.
His mouth curls into a smile, as he thinks,
“Well, we had a pretty good run.”
Still in his cell, SCP-049, the Plague Doctor,
puts his feet up and decides to relax.
The Pestilence will soon be taken care of.
On some animalistic level, below thought,
below even instinct, SCP-096 feels grateful
that no gaze will ever fall upon it again.
Somewhere, fizzling in a vat of acid within
a highly secure containment chamber, SCP-682
is feeling, for the first time in its hellish
existence, a sense of profound relief.
The pain, the hate, the rage, the constant
termination attempts.
It’d all be over soon.
Hour twenty-three.
People gather in the streets.
They laugh and dance and sing, as the moon
shines, fat and white, far above.
Deep in their hearts, they quietly contemplate
the end of all this.
But why worry?
Why spoil the fun?
There’s no future left to worry about.
Strangers become as close as family in the
end.
Human or otherwise, anomalous or non-anomalous.
Chaos Insurgency agents have last suppers
with ex-Serpent’s Hands and GOC operatives.
There is no hate left.
No violence.
No malice.
No cruelty.
The greatest tragedy in all of this is that
it took the ultimate end to bring it out in
people.
But why worry?
Why worry?
Seconds pass, then minutes.
The world buzzes.
It hums.
Trillions of creatures, doing everything they’d
always wanted, even though they know it won’t
last.
In the face of the true end, the world has
never been more alive.
Hour twenty-four.
Silence.
Forever, and ever, and ever...Goodnight.
We’ll end this video the way it began, by
putting a question to you: How would you spend
your last 24 hours on earth?
Let us know down in the comments.
Because it’ll happen to all of us eventually.
For decades upon decades, conspiracy theories
have long captured the minds of many individuals
and groups across the world.
The infamous ones will always spring to mind
the moment somebody so much as speaks the
phrase “conspiracy theory” aloud; the
words alone conjure up questions like “were
the moon landings really faked?”, “did
aliens really have a hand in building the
pyramids?”, and “is there really a shadowy,
ancient order called the Illuminati controlling
the events of the world around us?”
Of course, the answer to all of these questions
is often a plain and resounding “no, now
please leave me alone”, but delving into
the world of conspiracy theories, collecting
and connecting evidence can be an interesting
exercise in imagination when it’s all done
in good fun.
But there is often a dangerous side to conspiracy
theories as well, and we don’t mean getting
so close to the truth that the men in black
show up at your front door and haul you away
to Area 51.
No, it’s important to remember the harm
that some conspiracy theories can do.
It’s an unfortunate truth that a number
of conspiracy theories, especially those more
prevalent in recent years, are often used
to unjustly villainize particular religious
or ethnic minorities.
Positing about ancient aliens can be fun when
you remember that conspiracy theories have
no actual bearing on the real world, but the
line has to be drawn somewhere; the minute
a ‘theory’ starts to delve into unseemly
territory, it’s best to realize that there’s
very little truth to it.
There is one infamous conspiracy theory, not
a vindictive or harmful one, that has stood
the test of time for almost as long as the
moon landings or Area 51.
Who really killed President John F Kennedy?
We all know, or think we know what really
happened on November 22, 1963, on that fateful
day in Dallas Texas.
But what if that’s the point, we all think
we know, but each of us thinks differently?
Grab your red string and shiniest tinfoil
hats and take a seat, folks.
Welcome to SCP-001, otherwise known by the
appropriate nickname, The Conspiracy.
Now, first things first, some important information.
Anyone familiar with the SCP Foundation will
tell you that there are multiple entities
and objects referred to as SCP-001.
Everyone has some idea which of these they
think is the real one.
But, just in case you happen to be new here,
we’ll clarify for you.
The designation “SCP-001” doesn’t refer
to a single creature, object, or entity within
the Foundation’s archive.
Instead, it’s a collection of various anomalies
that have been encountered and - mostly - contained
by the SCP Foundation.
As for why these various files are all collected
under this shared designation?
Well, that’s a conspiracy theory all in
itself.
It could be that these anomalies are some
of the earliest ever contained by the Foundation,
and were first encountered before they had
established the numbering system that they
currently use.
However, could these multiple SCP-001s be
an intentional misdirection?
Smells like another conspiracy to us...
Among the anomalies sharing the title of SCP-001
is the Gate Guardian, a powerful being believed
to be an angel standing at the entrance to
the Garden of Eden.
Then there’s the infamous Scarlet King,
another anomalous eldritch creature with similar
levels of destructive power, who is intent
on one day causing the destruction of all
creation.
Also known as SCP-001 is a Database containing
all of the proof the Foundation’s top brass
have collected that proves their entire universe
is the fictional creation of the SCP Wiki
authors.
Pretty wild stuff.
And then, there’s this SCP-001, the Conspiracy
itself.
As we mentioned before, it’s connected to
the assassination of United States President
John F Kennedy; very closely connected, at
least for a few seconds before it came out
the other side, that is, because in this instance,
SCP-001 is the bullet that killed JFK.
Now, history tells us that on Friday, November
22, 1969, the 35th President of the United
States John Fitzgerald Kennedy, was riding
in an open-top car as part of a presidential
motorcade traveling through Dealey Plaza,
in Dallas, Texas.
A former US Marine named Lee Harvey Oswald
opened fire on the President through the window
of a nearby building, tragically killing JFK.
But, ever since Kennedy’s death, there has
been rampant speculation about what really
happened in Dallas.
Most theories suggest that there was a secret
organization involved or multiple shooters
in addition to Lee Harvey Oswald.
According to the Foundation, through some
anomalous means, the shot that killed John
F Kennedy was fired by multiple unidentified
assailants, acting as part of the same - or
numerous - conspiracies, all shooting at the
exact same moment.
The events surrounding the bullet’s trajectory
are designated under the codename Incident-001-Gamma.
Anyone alive that has memories linked to Incident-001-Gamma
is part of the last population on Planet Earth
that can agree on a shared concept of truth.
They know what is true, thanks to all sharing
an experience of either hearing about the
Kennedy Assassination, or witnessing it in
person or on television.
When SCP-001 was fired, it created Incident-001-Gamma,
which was both a pivotal moment in history
and also had a lasting effect on everything
that followed.
It might not be obvious how just yet, but
we’ll get to the repercussions in a moment.
The fact that multiple generations alive at
the time of Incident-001-Gamma have a consistent
memory of it, establishes a baseline.
Essentially, because these people have vivid
memories of the assassination, they also have
a societal memory of everything that had occurred
in human history up until that day in 1969.
The evolution of mankind, the various wars
that occurred had all been documented and
were held to be true.
There was a shared, collective truth among
Earth’s entire population, up until Incident-001-Gamma
occurred.
However, reality had shattered in some way,
the moment that SCP-001 was shot towards JFK.
The sheer number of conspiracy theories that
tumbled out of the Kennedy Assassination weren’t
just rampant speculation.
Not only did everyone on Earth now have a
memory of what happened, they had their own
version of what they believed they had remembered.
For example, from the moment that Incident-001-Gamma
took place and JFK was shot, there were already
conflicting witness testimonies from people
who were actually present in Dallas and saw
it all happen.
A significant percentage of eyewitnesses reported
some variation of seeing a strange, unidentified
figure referred to only as ‘Badge Man’.
Whoever he was, even if he was just a result
of civilians being unfamiliar with seeing
Secret Service agents, not everyone that was
present at Incident-001-Gamma can agree if
Badge Man was even there at all.
The only two people that were definitely participants
in the assassination were President Kennedy
and Lee Harvey Oswald.
History diverged for everyone from this point
on, remembering everything that came before,
but having conflicting memories of Incident-001-Gamma
and everything that followed it.
What the SCP Foundation knows for a fact,
is that Lee Harvey Oswald fired three shots
from his vantage point on the sixth floor
of the Texas Schoolbook Depository.
The first missed, the second delivered a wound
to the President as well as Texas Governor
John Connally who was riding in the same car
as JFK.
The third and final shot was SCP-001, which
vaporized the cranial cavity, killing him
and causing Incident-001-Gamma.
From that moment on, there now existed a confusing
and contradictory number of different perspectives
on the world’s history, all conflicting
with one another.
People’s perceptions began to divert away
from reality over the course of the next decade,
slowly and unnoticeably at first.
Everyone could still agree on what had happened
since Incident-001-Gamma for the most part,
until September 5th, 1975, the failed assassination
of Gerald Ford, the 38th President of the
US.
Multiple witnesses reported seeing different
versions of the event, some even certain that
President Ford was, in fact, killed.
This even resulted in another attempt on Ford’s
life only two weeks later by a woman who believed
the President was already dead, attempting
to make reality align with what she thought
to be real.
But it gets worse, President Ford had equally
been affected by SCP-001, believing that the
Soviet Union had withdrawn from Eastern Europe
during the Nixon administration.
In reality, this didn’t occur until the
late 1980s.
That is the true effect of SCP-001, the disparity
between what someone perceives to be real
and what is actually real.
It can often manifest in frustration, we’ve
all once felt that we have the skills required
when applying for a job, only to have a rejection
email sent back to us.
Some of us believe ourselves to be kind, good-hearted
people, yet can’t seem to find any friends
that would agree.
Living in a huge house can make a person feel
cramped and claustrophobic despite all the
space around them.
You can feel that there is something wrong
in situations like this, but you can’t explain
it.
This effect of SCP-001 can often result in
conditions like Imposter Syndrome, where someone
has the belief that all of their achievements
and successes are nothing more than a sham,
and that the best parts of their lives are
destined to fall apart because that person
does not deserve them.
That feeling of not belonging, the world not
aligning with what you think is true, all
comes from SCP-001.
The phenomenon known as the “Mandela Effect”
is also seemingly derived from the fractalization
that occurred after Incident-001-Gamma.
The Mandela Effect usually refers to a memory
held by an individual, or group of individuals,
that they believe to be true, but actually
differs from fact.
For example, the effect is named after Nelson
Mandela, who died in 2013.
However, countless people distinctly remember
news that Mandela had died in prison during
the 80s.
Misremembering history comes as a result of
a person’s perception and their living memory
being out of sync with that which is true.
Often, trying to undo the effects of SCP-001
can be more harmful to a person as having
their perception vary so dramatically from
reality.
Say you believed that all the Beatles were
still alive, you were positive of it and it
had always been that way all your life.
Then, somebody presented you with actual historical
proof that John Lennon was killed outside
his hotel in the year 1980.
All the photographs, news reports, and other
evidence in the world couldn’t convince
you that what you thought to be true, in fact,
wasn’t.
Frequently, this leads to frustration and
confusion that could, and often does, damage
relationships with friends and family, causing
isolation and disconnection of social associations.
If everyone is telling you that John Lennon
died, but you can’t believe it because it
doesn’t match your own perception, you would
gravitate towards people whose alternative
viewpoints overlapped with yours.
This is how echo chambers form, which spread
and strengthen conspiracy theories, often
making them more resilient against outside
logic - as well as more extreme and pernicious.
So, who really did kill President John F Kennedy?
Ask Lee Harvey Oswald, he’d say he didn’t
do it and was instead being framed.
Ask Fidel Castro and he’d tell you that
he and his men were there in Dallas that day,
armed and on a mission to kill Kennedy themselves.
Or there’s the “Umbrella Man”, who claimed
he killed JFK with a modified umbrella.
But ultimately, speculating as to who killed
President Kennedy is pointless: every answer
is right to someone.
SCP-001 was the shot that changed the entire
world.
Since Incident-001-Gamma, nobody has been
able to perceive the world in the exact same
way as someone else does.
If you feel confused, rely on what you know
to be real, what you believe is the truth,
and find comfort in the normalcy of that.
Honestly, it’s all you really have.
At the time of this video’s writing, the
SCP Foundation currently contains well over
6000 items.
This organization really gets around, from
making deals with deities to containing horrors
capable of ending the world in a heartbeat.
So it’s hard to think of this secret group
ever having “Humble Beginnings”, but everyone
and everything has to start somewhere, right?
And would you believe that one of the most
powerful groups in the world all started with
a little sheaf of papers?
Of course, that’s if this particular iteration
of SCP-001 is to be believed.
That’s right, we once again return to SCP-001,
the gift that keeps on taking.
It’s a heavily contested spot, currently
held by over thirty different contradictory
anomalies and counting.
Their natures vary from things that started
the Foundation to things more than capable
of ending it, along with the rest of the world,
and everything in between.
The Scarlet King, The Gate Guardian, and the
ever-eccentric Dr. Wondertainment all exist
under this banner.
But today, we want to talk about a little
stack of paper, bound by a single staple in
the top left corner.
Who would have guessed that something this
simple would not only be pivotal in the creation
of the SCP Foundation as we know it today
but could also be one of the most dangerous
items ever discovered?
We realize this is a lot to take in.
Keeping with the SCP-001 spirit, let’s take
it all the way back to the beginning, to the
fine oak desk of the late...hmmm...uhhh, I
guess uhhhh...
Oh, we don’t have the name?
Shame.
Let’s just call him The First Administrator.
He’s the head honcho of a precursor to the
Foundation as we know it today, a rinky-dink
little organization with the thankless task
of keeping the paranormal under wraps.
We’re talking a long, long time ago here.
No lanky freaks who kill everybody who sees
their face, no gloopy sadists who can walk
through walls, no giant unkillable reptiles
with major anger issues.
This organization - let’s call them The
Precursors - was dealing with the real small
fries.
Paranoiacs reporting ghost sightings in their
garden sheds, old ladies finding the face
of Jesus in a piece of toast, abnormally large
and strangely-shaped potato chips.
Okay, maybe not that small-time, but you get
the idea.
Truly exceptional anomalies were few and far
between, until the sheaf of papers landed
on the dearly deceased Administrator’s desk.
He didn’t even know how exactly the papers
got there, but given the numbers of mostly
junk files that passed his desk every day,
he wasn’t in the business of questioning.
The words “Confidential Report on Special
Items—Classified” were printed on the
front.
This made it more interesting than 90% of
the files he read on a daily basis already,
so he turned the first page and began to read.
It was much stranger than the usual paranormal
reports that the Precursor Foundation processed.
No late-night wailing or rattling chains.
Instead, it was a surprisingly sterile report
about a bizarre and frightening anomaly: A
large, fleshy, tumor-like object fixed to
a set of metal stairs.
Inside the object is a seemingly normal living
room, but on closer inspection, all the furniture
is made out of living human tissue and flesh.
Anyone who steps inside is transformed into
more nightmarish living furniture.
The Administrator gave a nervous chuckle.
It was disturbing, sure, but Stephen King
wrote about disturbing things all the time,
and that didn’t mean that the Foundation
needed to be on the lookout for an evil clown
- Well, until SCP-993, the sinister Bobble
the Clown, would enter the Foundation’s
radar a few years later.
The Administrator put the file into his incredibly
disorganized filing cabinet, and prepared
to go home and drink bourbon until he fell
asleep.
That’s exactly when his office phone began
to ring.
When The Administrator picked up the phone,
he heard the excited voice of one of his field
agents, telling him they’d just scored the
find of the century: A giant sphere made from
living flesh with a room inside it.
Finally, an honest to god, terrifying paranormal
anomaly!
He could hardly believe what he was hearing.
He needed to grab and reread the file, just
to make sure he wasn’t going insane.
Where exactly did he put it?
He scrambled through the filing cabinet, tossing
aside the files on shed ghosts and burnt toast
Jesuses, until he found the file marked “Confidential
Report on Special Items—Classified.”
However, when he opened the file, there was
nothing about the giant, fleshy room in there.
It must have been a completely different file
that he’d somehow missed before, because
this one was about something known as the
“Biological Motherboard.”
The document detailed pretty much exactly
what the name suggested: A large and incredibly
complex motherboard made out of biological
material like keratin and chitin.
While the motherboard would remain inactive
if kept warm, if its environment ever fell
below 35 degrees, it would begin to expand,
integrating nearby material into its mass
and attempting to copy the structure of any
biological matter it comes into contact with.
An interesting and frightening prospect, but
not what he was looking for.
He threw this new file down onto his desk
and continued to work through his chaotic
filing cabinet like a madman, searching for
the file on that frightening fleshy room that
his subordinates had seemingly actually discovered.
But not long after, he received another phone
call from a completely different field agent.
This time, the agent was giddily telling the
Administrator about a new discovery: A huge
computer motherboard, seemingly made out of
entirely organic material!
The Administrator was floored.
He hung up the phone and slowly turned back
to the file now laying on his desk.
Those words on the cover, “Confidential
Report on Special Items—Classified”, seemed
almost mocking now.
Had all these incredible supernatural anomalies
been reported before and just lost in his
awful filing cabinet?
Was he one of the most incompetent team leaders
who’d ever walked the earth?
Just what exactly was going on here?
He sat back down at his desk, now fantasizing
about that tumbler of bourbon more than ever,
and opened the file again, hoping to read
up a little more on the impossible motherboard
that his personnel had just discovered.
But there was nothing about the Biological
Motherboard on these pages.
Instead, it described a large door inside
a factory, and the twelve rusty keys capable
of opening it.
Each of these keys would open the doorway,
but the key used would affect the reality
waiting for them on the other side.
Only the seventh and twelfth keys were safe,
opening the door with any of the others would
lead to a horrible death for anyone brave
or foolish enough to walk through.
Several days later, an anomaly matching that
exact description was discovered and contained
by the Foundation.
All of this had been an unprecedented escalation
of anomalous stakes.
Suddenly, two crucial facts clicked into place
for The Administrator: Firstly, this file
was an anomalous supernatural artifact of
its own.
Secondly, the reason it was never the same
thing was that this strange sheaf of papers
had a very specific purpose: To act as a kind
of oracle, an advanced warning system of the
next anomaly that would appear and fall into
their grasp, giving them all the knowledge
and tools they needed to safely lock these
things away.
The whole thing had been timed perfectly - what
a miracle that this immensely useful item
would appear in his office just as the anomalies
would start to come in thick and fast.
It would facilitate their mission in the coming
struggles to secure, contain, and protect
the world’s anomalies.
Hmm, there’s a certain ring to that, isn’t
there?
They were finding enough anomalies to start
classifying them numerically, starting with
the sheaf of papers themselves as SCP-001.
With another turn of the page, The Administrator
discovered a file on a magical key that can
open any lock.
Not long after, that exact key was discovered
and brought in, before being designated SCP-005.
Little by little, as more real anomalies came
in, the organization was able to expand and
bring in more personnel, as well as bringing
in more sources of funding and opening new
sites.
The rate this organization was expanding,
they couldn’t even leave management up to
one person anymore.
They needed to form a whole council to take
over management.
An O5 Council, if you will.
And it just so happened that just after that,
the sheaf of papers revealed a mythical spring
that could provide eternal health and vitality
for anyone who drinks from it.
What a perfect way to keep your management
safe in a job dealing with dangerous supernatural
entities.
And things only got stranger and more fascinating
from there.
After that came a man with a miniature version
of planet earth inside his abdomen, soon known
as SCP-007.
Next came a horrifying virus that kills and
reanimates its victims into flesh-eating zombies,
only capable of being destroyed with sufficient
trauma to the head, dubbed SCP-008 after containment.
Another turn of the page, and not long after,
a frightening red ice was discovered in Alaska.
This mysterious substance breaks the laws
of physics, and also has the potential to
break all life on earth.
It can infect water supplies, and when a hapless
lifeform happens to drink this water, their
organs crystalize from the inside.
This became SCP-009.
Another turn of the page, and this new SCP
Foundation found a collection of six metal
collars created for human-sized necks.
When these collars are placed around the necks
of a victim, the person holding a corresponding
controller has utter domination over their
every action.
It carried on like that.
Hundreds of anomalies, and then thousands.
Years passed, the staff changed, the old guard
stepped down or died.
Every time the sheaf of papers were opened,
new astonishing premonitions of anomalies
soon to be discovered slipped through.
There were Plague Doctors who could kill with
a touch.
A giant angel with bladed wings.
A sea snail that believed he was an English
lord.
A Sculpture that would kill anything that
dared to stop looking at it.
A nightmarish fusion of a giant bovine heart
and a scorpion, capable of setting things
on fire with its venom.
Whatever would the SCP Foundation have done
without the advanced warning system provided
by the sheaf of papers?
Whatever it predicted would inevitably be
the next thing Foundation field agents would
find.
It seems like one of the few unambiguously
good SCP-001 entries out there, right?
Well, not quite.
If we have any scientists in the audience,
they’ve no doubt been gritting their teeth
and pulling their hair out in frustration.
Allow us to introduce you to a little phrase
that the latest iteration of the O5 Council
is very interested in when it comes to the
sheaf of papers: “Direction of causality.”
This whole time, we and the earlier Foundation
administrations believed that the emergence
of new anomalies led to changes in SCP-001.
But this current administration has quite
the opposite question: What if the changes
in SCP-001 were actually causing the emergence
of new anomalies?
What if every time the prior administration
opened up the sheaf of papers to take a look
at the next anomaly, before giving themselves
a pat on the back for being so well-prepared,
they were actually unleashing that very anomaly?
Could it be that what had seemed like the
most helpful item of the bunch was actually
the most dangerous of them all, releasing
new anomaly after new anomaly, blighting the
world with countless horrors?
That probably leaves you with one question:
So, which is correct?
Is it a method of seeing the future, or manipulating
it?
And our answer is a strong...we don’t know.
But frankly, the current leadership of the
SCP Foundation sees no merit in taking that
risk.
That’s why the sheaf of papers has been
given the Keter Class designation, and is
kept under extensive and severe containment
methods, forbidding any future research into
the true nature of its anomalous abilities.
Seems a little severe, sure, but better safe
than sorry, right?